Hey everybody,
Joe Rogan experience podcast is brought
to you by audible.com.
If you go to audible.com
forward slash Joe,
you can get one free audio book and one
free month of a audible service.
You really should try it out.
It's an amazing service.
They have over 100,000
titles.
If you have never tried audio books
before,
it can really transform the way you
commute.
It makes being stuck in your car or
stuck on a train and makes it an
educational experience.
It can inspire you.
You can take in some cool fiction,
you can enjoy yourself.
Instead of feeling like a Schlub,
just wasting your life away,
enrich herself with audible.com
freaks.
It's an awesome way to get your learn on
m and a.
If you go there right now,
as I said,
you can get one free audio book.
A book I recommend is called the war of
art by Steven Pressfield.
It's an amazing book.
I give it out to people.
I have a stack of them at my house.
And um,
it's all about the,
it's all about overcoming resistance,
which is something that holds a lot of
us back when we procrastinate about
things,
we feel crappy about it,
but when we get things done,
we feel great.
But how many people actually follow
through and continue to get things done?
It's not that many.
And there's a lot of reasons why.
And Steven Pressfield is a brilliant
writer and the way he gets into it,
it'll sync with your head so quickly.
You'll be like,
oh,
that's my issue.
And then from then on you're always
going to know what the issue is
immediately when it massive manifests
itself.
And you'll look at it in a completely
different way.
I've told so many people about this book
and I've had so many people come back
and say,
this book completely changed the way I
work.
And,
uh,
for creative type folks,
it's amazing.
But I think it's amazing for anybody
because I think that whole resistance
thing in procrastination,
I think that sort of a plays a part in a
lot of people's lives.
I don't think it has anything to do with
just being artistic.
He relates it to writing and art and
creating things,
but I think it probably goes to a lot of
different things that you do in life.
The things that you put your focus
towards,
things that you enjoy.
Anyway.
Audible.com
forward slash joe were also brought to
you by onnit o n n I t.
We got a lot of new stuff in including a
club bells and mace balls and of course
we have kettle bells and battle ropes
and stuff like that.
If you,
uh,
I've never heard his podcast,
you don't know what it is.
It's essentially like a personal
performance website.
Like what we're interested in is all
different things and increase athletic
performance,
different things that increase mental
which are called nootropics.
And we saw one of those called Alpha
brain.
If you've heard this all before,
I swear to God,
I don't want to keep saying it like
this,
but there's no other way to do it.
They still clubs look like weapons.
Jail.
You're starting to add weapons to on it.
That's just the no weapons.
They will help you wield the weapon,
but what they are is a,
they're ancient Indian exercises.
Uh,
these are,
um,
from a boy that used to do them with
hardwoods like hundreds and hundreds of
years ago,
probably thousands of years ago.
And the awkward shape of them and the
balance of them makes you a,
strengthens up your forearms and your
grip.
And uh,
it's uh,
a great exercise as far as like
wrestling and hand strength and things
along those lines.
Club bells are fantastic.
You'd be surprised at how difficult they
are to use.
I only used five pounders throw that
hard to use,
like for,
with a 25 pound club bill,
I got a serious workout in.
It's real weird.
Like we look at weights and you know,
we looked at like lifting weight and you
know,
and people are all impressed if they can
lift 300 pounds and you know,
a bunch to 50.
It doesn't really matter if you can't
use it.
The stuff that I'm interested in is all
different exercises that have been shown
to actually increase athletic
performance.
What I'm interested in is improving the
way your body moves.
That's why we're interested in
kettlebells.
That's why we sell the extreme
kettlebell cardio DVD.
We have many different weights and sizes
of kettlebells.
We have medicine balls,
we have wall balls,
which are these big giant,
also looked like medicine balls.
You throw him against the wall and a
host of different supplements.
Anything that we've found anywhere that
we believe increases performance
increases your mood.
There's a supplement called new mood
that it increases your body's ability to
produce serotonin.
It,
it has five htp and l Tryptophan in it,
and uh,
it's,
it's great for your brain to check it
all out.
Go to [inaudible] dot com.
Use the code name,
Rogan,
and you will save 10 percent off any and
all supplements.
We're also brought to you by death
squad.tv
this Wednesday night right there,
a Thursday,
next Thursday,
Thursday,
next Wednesday.
If you do go into their brand sleeping
bag,
San Diego this Thursday night,
it'll be Brian,
Tony Hinchcliffe,
who's hilarious,
up and coming,
young comedian Jason t dot,
who we love to death.
Very,
very funny guy.
Billy bow,
now,
our buddy,
Yoshi,
you can't go wrong with this show.
It's a the American comedy company.
It's a cool ass club if you've never
been there before.
It's in San San Diego on sixth street is
where at in that area,
something like that.
You could find it on Google wherever,
but it's at the American comedy company.
It's an awesome comedy club.
San Diego as one of that.
That club is like one of the best design
clubs in the country,
like real low ceilings,
tight seeding.
I remember when we went there were like,
Whoa,
this place is sick.
This is a great spot.
It's going to be fun.
Yeah.
Next Thursday and Friday,
which is tonight.
Tonight.
Tonight we're at the icehouse 10:00
PM show.
It's a great show.
Thompson girl.
Christina pundits.
They didn't make it.
No,
they can't make enough,
but when
we had a huge show.
Anyways,
we have.
We have you.
We have Maddie Khurshid returning to the
comedy stage doing comedy recently.
Matt Medicaid used to open up for Rogan
back back in the day and he was one of
my favorite comics.
Who was hilarious.
Yeah,
and various hilarious,
so he's going to join us.
We also have Sam triply Johnny Pemberton
and Tony Hinchcliffe and Josh fattom and
Benji.
That's a good show.
All right.
Ten o'clock.
You're freaks and we'll see you there.
All right.
We have on the podcast Dr Amad Goswami.
Am I pronouncing her name correctly?
Sir?
We're going to get to the bottom of shit
folks.
We're going to learn some things.
He's going to enlighten us.
Are you ready?
Set.
Oh,
Joe.
Okay.
Experience Joe Rogan podcast all day.
We are here with Dr.
Goswami.
Thank you very much for doing this.
I really appreciate it.
I've seen a lot of your videos online.
I read a lot of your your work and it is
some very,
very fascinating and for a person is
dumb as I am confusing stuff.
The idea of quantum mechanics and the
just when someone uses the word quantum,
do you find that a lot of folks that
just eyes glaze over?
Well,
not anymore because you know the most
complex,
one of the most complex complex concepts
of quantum physics is quantum leap is
the discontinuous condition.
When that gives an idea of how foreign
it is to a mind which thinks in the
Newtonian fashion you don't.
Motion is continuous and quantum leap is
discontinuous,
but it's used everywhere today.
Everybody knows.
Right.
You know if anything unusual happened,
people say took a quantum leap,
so that has the.
What do they mean by that?
I think they just mean like a big jump.
I think they just been a big challenge.
It's a discontinuous jump.
They probably would hesitate and what
does that.
What does that exactly mean by
discontinuous jump?
I have to go back a little.
Okay,
so think of electrons going around the
atomic nucleus in anatomy.
Okay.
When electrons jump from one of these
orbits to another arbit,
it does not go to the intervening space.
However much surprising to your
restaurant.
Mind that is just suspend your
disbelief.
Imagine that the electron is here and
then the electron is there and the other
arpit nothing in between in space and
time,
not so it just some sort or another
they.
They teleport themselves or are
teleported.
That's it.
Science fiction language capture a
little bit,
but where do they go in between?
We have to say that,
uh,
they go to the domain of possibility.
That's what quantum physics brings that
reality,
which it seems to be just this one space
time reality that we call it nature.
That is not true.
There is another reality which must be
called supernature transcendent reality.
Just like this,
spiritual traditions are saying,
just like the psychologists are saying
in the turn of the century,
19th century pride discovered the
concept of unconscious,
unconscious conscious to all levels of
reality.
The spiritual traditions of
transcendent,
even again,
two levels of reality.
Quantum physics in the 20th century,
in the yard,
1925,
26,
discovered the same thing three times
the charm.
This time we better observe the idea and
learn to live with,
but there are two levels of our reality.
Quantum physics says one level is level
of possibility.
Wherever taken is possibility.
Nothing concrete,
no king,
no king this,
and then this level of reality,
who are we of course live where we find
things manifest,
what things look like.
They're particles,
objects,
concrete,
solid liquid gases.
All of these are concrete objects.
We have become used to them as concrete
objects,
but they begin as possibilities in a
transcendent,
so to break it down for the lay person,
essentially the lowest form or the
smallest form of the universe that we
can measure when we get to subatomic
particles,
when we can look at subatomic particles,
they defy the laws of physics.
They exist in the same space at the same
time,
in two different places.
They can be both moving and still and
they can teleport themselves
a little more complex than it actually
is.
It's less complex than that.
Less complex than thou because we have
to realize these objects can be shown to
be at two places at the same time,
but only in possibility.
No,
but that's.
You have to think about it.
I try and I just broke my brain because
to work possibilities familiar to this
is why we did a couple of hours to write
her own days because they're a little
bit strange what is possibility,
but we know what possibilities.
Possibilities are things that glimpse at
us,
but nothing that we can put our finger
to it because this so they become fact,
but right now it's just an idea right
now.
It's just an idea.
So it,
it begins with our reality begins with
these possibilities.
A possibility of an electron being
anywhere in the room.
Our knowledge is limited.
We only know that it's possible to find
the electron here.
They're at the ceiling maybe at here,
right?
I am,
but we don't know,
but it actually will be if I actually
tried to see it,
try to measure it,
try to observe it,
and that's the second domain.
Second domain is the domain of
manifestation.
When an observer tries to measure where
the electron is,
the observer will find it at a definite
place as a particle.
That's the manifest reality.
So something that is a wave of
possibility being,
having the capacity of being everywhere
without measurement becomes the concrete
object that we can say,
well,
it's a thing there it is at a definite
place.
So by only by measuring it and measuring
it,
I'm only by.
That's a very hard thing to understand.
It is very hard to understand,
but isn't it if you're measuring it and
that's when it becomes a a concrete
object,
isn't it?
Just assuming it wasn't a concrete
object before you measured it and that
it's always a concrete object.
That's the team you hadn't measured it
before.
That's the thing.
Today we have a new era of physics in
which we can propose something which you
cannot actually see what the consequent.
Don't listen to this.
Please let the consequences of it can be
seen.
So our theories are so good that what we
have visualized as theory,
the consequences of it is predicted so
very well that we got to believe this
theory.
There's no choice because the
consequences of predicted like one part
in $100 million to that kind of
accuracy.
So this is the kind of theory that just
boggles your mind.
We've never had the capacity of
predicting something this accurately.
So when the picture says that,
well they started as possibility and
then they become actually to have no
option but to accept it.
Although I agree with you,
it,
it sounds strange.
I mean anytime you're talking about
supernature,
most people will say,
well,
we already knew land,
but you are not in Ireland.
We are in quantum reality where quantum
reality is,
Ooh,
land also real.
That is also the thing that people need
to.
Uh,
I mean I've had a really hard time
adjusting any of this stuff,
but the thing that people need to look
at first I think is the idea of
superposition.
The idea that,
what you were saying,
the idea that they have measured things
both moving and still at the same time
and they have shown that things can leap
from one place to another.
So our real reality as far as science,
as far as like accepted pretty much
universally,
right?
There's no,
there's no debate in the scientific
community about the movement of
Subatomic particles right now.
Somebody subatomic particles involving
discontinuing,
there is no debate.
So that becomes tables.
That becomes Dr.
Goswami,
that becomes
the laptop.
That's,
that is a real tricky thing to try to
wrap your head around Vl trippy thing
that when you go the smaller you go,
the more it becomes magic,
it becomes,
it becomes something that doesn't exist
in.
In our rational world,
it's different.
More and tricking them.
Debt.
Let me claim the full claim of quantum
physics is not only saying that the
smaller you go,
but they've brought chickens.
When you realized that the reality at
the macro scale is made of this small
tanks,
so of course they affect is visible much
more easily measured in this part,
the small things,
but when the small things make big
thing,
as you said,
microphones and you and me,
our body that is,
they're all quantum objects,
so we also,
when nobody is observing us,
including ourselves,
like when we sleep deep sleep,
no body is observing me.
Where am I?
I am only a possibility.
The only reason I can.
I can find myself in the same bed every
night when I wake up.
The only reason for that is that because
I'm a macro object,
my waiver possibility,
although it expansive,
just as always must expand.
You have seen water.
We've expanding,
you know,
in Detroit Bebo my pebble have what?
The water,
the water waves will expand,
right?
Same thing happens with west.
The possibility we do tend to expand
when as soon as you go to sleep as a way
of a possibility,
but the waves are so sluggish or macro
objects for me to move substantial
distance that somebody can discern it.
It'll take the edge of the universe so
we don't discern it.
It moves like 10 to the minus 16
centimeter,
but today with leisure beams,
we can actually measure such small
distances that these macro objects,
even macro objects move while Newtonian
physics of setting.
No,
no.
They're addressed.
What are common sense to say,
no,
they are not moving.
But with leisure beam we can actually
measure that between your looking and my
looking just great.
Second objects actually moves which
appear to be stressed and have a totally
normal.
Right?
So we live in a heavy,
heavy,
wonderfully,
a creative world wide creative because
this movement also suggest something
fantastic that there are new
possibilities and if we could capture
those new possibilities and make them
manifest,
that takes prednisone of creativity.
So this what you're saying is that
objects like this desk are not,
in fact still what are slightly moving
slightly moving all the time and what is
the number that they're moving,
how far it.
It's fairly at the center
of mass of this table.
For example,
it's a pretty massive property.
Moving a block tend to the minus 18
centimeters in a dishonorable time,
like a minute
too.
So it just sort of moves back and forth.
And so the whole world we really do live
in like a holiday.
Well Hello Graham is not always the good
better for pet.
It is for this case because the objects
kind of appeared in more than one place.
In that sense,
Hologram,
the information appears everywhere on
the Hologram.
So these objects carry information which
is in more than one place potentially.
It is more than one one place.
This is why we say that we have
discovered a new world of potential from
which our ordinary reality is created,
so ordinary reality is not as fixed as
they taught it to us.
If you allow the objects to go more and
more into quantum domain in the realm of
expansion into new possibility,
that while it has not expanded before,
not so much with tables and chairs,
mine too,
but we taught tarts with our feelings.
Then we can really get into creativity.
So how would you do that?
How do you go into the quantum domain
with your creativity?
Bam.
That's when then I have to talk to you
about the creative process.
If you look at the creative process,
creativity,
researchers have found that there are
four stages.
The first stage everybody knows
preparing.
That just added up.
I talked with you.
I get some knowledge from picking your
brand.
I listened to a teacher.
I listen to audios,
videos,
Internet of course,
and get some knowledge about the
subject,
and then creativity such as find a very
French thing happens the most creative
people that are not just doing
preparation.
They also sit quietly and do nothing.
They really sit quietly and do nothing.
They call it the period of incubation,
like a bird sits on an egg,
doing nothing.
See Magic.
It was a tremendous surprise.
Nobody understood,
why do we need to sit down in the
creativity after all his action?
Why do we need to sit down quietly?
You need to do nothing,
and then quantum physicists come along
and realized that in between our
thinking,
these objects talks.
They are possibilities of meaning that
waves.
So like always as talking about the
water,
where before if a toy pebble in a pond,
the water goes to expand as expanding
crest lines.
So same thing happens with the thoughts
they expand in meaning become wave.
Some multiple meanings,
possibilities of multiple meaning,
multiple meaning expanding,
expanding,
expanding.
The more they expand,
the more meaning this packet of
possibility or contained and so you have
a better idea,
better possibility,
better probability of,
of capturing a new meaning because if
you have a bigger possibility pool to
choose from,
obviously your chance of being creative
is greater.
This is the idea that has explained how
creativity comes to us.
Then when the actual answer appears,
the new meaning that we are seeking,
when it appears in the pool,
and when I see the gestalt of all the
new meanings that'll give answer to my
problem,
then I fake it.
Then I choose it still in the
unconscious.
That's where my causal power of
creativity lies in the unconscious,
but now it becomes conscious with the
hormone.
This is the quantum leap at this
continuous change from possibility to
actuality.
So I actually captured the new job.
I actually captured the new thought and
and that's so surprising because it's
new creativity,
researcher,
scholar,
Aha insight.
You have a heart of our heart.
So the idea is that the imagination is a
quantum realm.
Imagination takes us to the jail.
More possibility if we can do it from
conscious into the unconscious.
Conscious imagination is still a
stepping stone to they're doing a
possibility,
but if we imagined consciously,
that is like stoking the unconscious.
That eventually gets into the
unconscious,
and this is where things have this
capacity of propagating,
expanding,
wavelight becoming bigger and bigger.
Pools of possibility for consciousness
to choose from and when we choose a new
possibility might arise or the whole
combination of new possibilities my
learner might arise which are contained.
The answer to my question,
that's a very interesting way to break
down creativity that I've never heard
before.
Absolutely.
This is,
I'm not,
although it is not that old.
I wrote a paper on it in 1988,
so,
but you know how communication is today.
It's very complex because there is too
much of it,
but it,
it is a,
it is a fantastic theory that explains
all the aspects of creativity,
material,
creativity,
experiments,
kegerator data.
Um,
the other theories are just inadequate
to explain the creative process.
As I said,
just very mysterious.
I call it the Doobie Doobie.
Do process because you need to do,
but you also need to be doing nothing to
create,
to create the key or the creation
process has always been fascinating to
me and I,
I've been saying this for awhile.
Then I think we don't understand.
We have the idea of the imagination of
what's in the mind as being just,
Oh,
pretend.
Make believe daydreaming like that.
Those,
those things come to mind when we think
of imagination,
but everything physical that exists was
created in the imagination of the
imagination is a machine for creating
cities.
The imagination created power.
The imagination created satellites.
I mean these are all because of the
imagination.
Without the human imagination,
there would be nothing.
Well yes,
and now we look at it frivolously,
but quantum physics is taking a little
bit further it.
Imagination is a good starting point.
As I said,
lack of imagination is still in our
conscious talk,
so we have to understand that when we
have conscious talks of imagination,
then we are proposing the unconscious to
look at new stuff,
process new stuff.
This is what we are doing.
What imagination takes us is from
ordinary reality,
mundane reality that a familiar stuff,
imagination inbetween hopster.
Beyond that,
it's imagination.
It's not going to confirm to the to the
mundane stuff necessarily read.
We can imagine very arbitrary stuff,
so what it does,
it starts the beginning of a thought
process where talks can become more and
more and more and more weird and more
and more and more and more new,
but they're no longer process.
It's no longer possible to process them
into conscious because then the
conscious,
we just kind of do it.
We don't have the capacity.
We are still limited by what we know
they known imposes too much constraint
on what we can imagine in the domain of
the unknown,
but as soon as it gets into the
unconscious unconscious stuff,
more reimagine the imaginary stuff will
interact with other imaginary stuff that
talks will mix and this mixing waves
together will produce patterns,
self logical patterns of interference of
waves.
Even mentioning super position with
super superpose and creating many,
many more new possibilities than before
and one of these possibilities may very
well be brand new that the effort has
been manifested before.
So it's always a mystery.
How do we go from the known into the
unknown?
The way we go is this taking advantage
of what we call quantum thinking,
thinking where we take advantage of the
quantum domain.
They told me in a possibility where a
possibility interacting with possibility
create sub completely new stuff that has
never manifested before.
I've heard you say that you believe that
consciousness is non nonlocal,
right?
What do you mean by that?
Well,
if discontinuity.
See,
you are already familiar with
discontinuities.
Now you want to know even most,
most unfamiliar,
most intriguing.
You know this is.
This is like Voodoo.
This is really good.
Now getting into real cracks of the most
surprising thing in quantum physics that
surprised even Einstein.
Einstein in his whole life could not
believe this concept of nonlocality,
which he himself discovered with two
other later on.
How did they discover it?
How to discover just theory.
You know,
understanding what the tour addition.
He never shouldn't say never.
We could probably do the experiments in
his young days when he was a graduate
student,
I did took that.
Theories don't do an experiment.
No.
What they do is this,
a creative exploration of the mind by
that day to find new ideas,
the new ideas,
and then they then to predict stuff.
So I starting a idea was,
and this is 1935 mind to understanding
idea,
was that if quantum objects to quantum
objects interact,
they become correlated.
And this is a new word that he used in
that paper.
He and his collaborators have Rosen and
photos,
um,
these people that really sound in that
theory,
that mathematics,
that if two objects once become
correlated,
they kniffen when they're not
interacting,
even if they move away from each other,
even then they can communicate,
not in the usual way,
not interacting with signals.
Then the ducks fuse will,
you and I are interacting right now,
but we are interacting through a
complexity of soundwave,
sudden electrical wires to this
microphones.
That's all true signals,
but these objects communicate without
signals.
So their communication use as a medium
that can only be outside of space and
time.
Because in space and time,
Einstein himself gave us a theory of
relativity which says that nothing can
interact without exchanging signals
going through space and time,
but these objects,
quantum objects once correlated,
they have the capacity of signal less
communication.
This is what is called non local signals
that local going through space,
taking them out of them,
how they measure that these particles
are communicating.
So the key is in that they measure the
communication and the soul,
that there is no signal because the
communication took place faster than the
speed of light in all local signal going
to space and time must travel either at
the speed of light or less than the
speed of light.
So if something can be shown to travel
faster than the speed of light,
it has to be non local.
And this is what a physicist discovered
in the laboratory I learned in 1982.
Finally verified by Einstein was dead
long time ago,
1955.
So he never knew that his theory was one
day.
Not only prove to variety,
but really revolutionized the whole
world of physics by bringing in concepts
of consciousness.
So what did they measure when you're
measuring information that transfers
between two particles?
What are they measuring?
The experiment?
Is that a little bit complex?
Probably for a store like this?
Um,
but I can give you stuff for that.
I just don't know if it's intriguing.
They definitely are also easy to
understand because there is no signal is
easy to understand how to detect it is a
little more difficult because you have
to talk about four times and Portland's
come with a characteristic
characteristic called polarization and
you get more and more technical and I'm
sure your listeners will get a little
dry.
They will,
they'll run away.
But,
but we don't go that far.
Let's put it this way.
If,
if,
if we had it and address certain atoms
with relationship,
then they met.
Sometimes I pair of photons one going
this way,
one going that way.
So what these experimenters did one
experiment or was measuring this photon
over here.
The other one was measuring the photon
over there in the laboratory is still
separated by a laboratory distance
several meters.
But the way the communication went,
they could flip.
This is what takes,
gets a little complicated.
They could flip the prioritization
access of the one of the photons and the
other for transportation access seem to
have flipped instantly.
They could show this by the technology
that we have now,
Huh?
So it was faster than the speed of light
and that shows that there's not a local
communication that shows around local
communication between these two tiles.
In case you're wondering what they are.
Quanta of light in this could bundle
stoplight.
Now,
how does that correlate to nonlocal
consciousness?
How to correlate to nonlocal
consciousness is the strangest thing
that physics is bringing.
The the reason common consciousness
enters physics was clear even to
Heisenberg.
That was back in the 19 twenties when
Heisenberg discovered his theory.
He himself said that,
okay,
what is happening when we measure a
quantum object before measurement,
we knew the object only vaguely.
Possibly the object is here somewhere.
That's all we knew.
We could only talk about possibility and
probability,
but after we measure is a change in our
knowledge about the object.
We know what the object is exactly.
We have measured so from vague knowledge
to concrete knowledge.
This is what the measurement is about.
Now,
notice the word knowledge was used.
What is knowledge?
Now,
if you look at the word consciousness,
it comes from two Latin words come which
is con with and the rest of the work
comes from the Latin words,
Cuba as C I r,
e,
scooter,
which means to know.
So consciousness is the entity we
twitch.
We know so in this way,
what is happening when we measure it?
Change in consciousness.
So hence,
Heisenberg himself was thinking about
that measurement process must involve
consciousness.
How to prove it.
John von Neumann,
uh,
took the crucial step.
He showed that the to change an object,
a material object from possibility to
actuality that concrete math,
you could not do this with.
And material interaction,
no material interactions can ever change
a possibility with,
into a particle of actuality.
I'll think about it if material
interactions cannot do it,
what is needed is some nonmaterial
interaction.
Does that mean those molecules are
conscious in some sort of way?
Well,
that means that consciousness within
consciousness must be otherwise.
There'll be duality.
So they are not,
we don't set that molecules are
conscious,
but we some molecules,
but have to be.
We did consciousness because if
consciousness is the ground of being and
molecules,
atoms,
solid objects,
objects,
everything is within consciousness as
waves of possibility.
Then we can think of this force that
changes possibility to actuality as a
conscious choice because what is a
possibility where,
but a packet of multi faceted potential,
lots of stuff can happen,
right?
Multi-Facets and consciousness users,
that particular facet that becomes
concretized,
that becomes sexualized.
So in this way we have found not only
the force that consciousness implies
that changes possibility to actuality,
but we know the nature of that force.
It consists of choice,
consciousness chooses.
And so why is non locality coming in?
So how does consciousness choose in an
experiment like a space?
Here is a possibility of photon.
Here is another possibility of Fortuyn
consciousness must be choosing them
simultaneously because otherwise
there'll be no non local communication.
So the local
communication proves that there is some
form of consciousness going on,
but a non vocal communication troops
that there is some form of matrix that
it that is involved with the
communication that is faster than the
that pervades faster than the speed of
light communication and therefore must
be outside of space and time.
So there's a connection that we can't
measure.
There was a connection that we can
theorize about and that connection has
to be consciousness because it involves
a change about knowledge
Gulf consciousness the same way
universally because what you're saying
is an instantaneous distribution of
information.
Whereas I think what a lot of people
think of as consciousness is,
is being sentient.
Yeah,
that too.
But this is the.
This is the.
This is the original consciousness.
This is the stuff.
This is the base,
this is the base to stop.
So this is why we connected to spiritual
tradition so much.
You must have heard that the new science
is connecting science and spirituality
and once it gets down to the Voodoo,
they almost have to know when you get
down to those quantum particles,
you go,
okay,
what else you got?
What you got over here,
man,
I don't want to sit down.
Exactly right.
So like in Buddhism,
terroristic score,
one,
just surprising lines that you hear and
then that sort of job.
What does your face before you were
born,
you see the possibility in that
parallel,
what does your face,
what is the face of an electron before
it is born of what is the sound of 100
clapping,
right?
One Hand clapping,
Very poignant sentences.
What does that mean?
Well,
Tim in quantum physics was the sound of
one hand clapping possibility.
The sound of one hand clapping is no
sound,
no sound possibility,
only possibility of sound or something
is there.
Because if he hears something that will
be sound right.
If it takes the other hand,
so if it makes contact with something
else in the realm,
right?
I still don't understand how that
relates to human consciousness being non
local instead of contained inside the
brain,
so I'm coming to that.
Okay,
so then they say the consciousness as
the ground of being.
When it chooses,
we get actuality.
So when you force one,
the polarity of one to change,
the other one chooses to stay with it,
stay with it,
and that's a concrete measure.
Concrete measurement,
right?
And possibility became measured
concrete.
We're saying that the,
that the medium that chooses is the
medium called consciousness.
The unconscious straight at that time,
but now when the measurement action has
taken place,
there are.
There has to be two observers with
brains in those locations because
consciousness just does not measured
arbitrarily.
Right?
But the,
the idea of those of it changing,
it has to be conscious to change.
It can't be just a reaction.
There is consciousness and there is this
observers.
What I'm saying is not only we need the
concept of nonlocal consciousness
connecting the objects,
connecting the observers,
but we also need the need to get the
concept that at the same time there is
nonlocal consciousness,
nonmaterial consciousness chosen.
At the same time,
there must also be the observer because
without the observer,
you never see anything.
Have you ever.
Can you ever imagine finding something
without an observer without a censhare,
so you have to measure the effect of the
Observer.
The Observer is Austin got the presence
of the observer changes the experiment.
The presidents of separate which changes
the experiment.
Presidents of the observer is essential
for the experiment itself.
Not only nonlocal consistency,
it says central,
but so is the observers,
and you have to factor that in when
considering the possibility of nonlocal
consciousness.
You have to factor that in when
considering the possibility of
actualizing actualizing the possibility
without individual consciousness
looking.
No actualization ever x place.
So nonlocal consciousness is a question
sort of.
It's a,
it's a,
it's an unconscious existence.
Things are processed,
but nothing concrete happens in nonlocal
consciousness.
Only when the observer is there.
Then this concretization that we are
calling,
we use the word collapsed,
the webs collapse into the particle.
What does this imply that before you
existed,
nothing else did as well.
I mean,
what does this imply?
So it implies something very strange to
absolve.
Initially what it implies is that before
it looked you yourself did not exist
before you.
You didn't even exist.
I understand that.
But can we assume that all this other
shit was already here?
That's it.
So the looking process of looking at the
process of collapse,
pub sub changing possibility and to
actually do not only creates the object,
it creates the very subject that you've
experienced you.
You're looking at you personally,
but to all the other people that you
live in the neighborhood with these,
these buildings were real before you got
there.
No,
no,
no.
They are.
Well,
they're real as possibility,
but that not real as actually in your
world or in the world period.
Or is your world the whole world?
Will it?
Somebodies got to be present in order to
get.
Actually I cannot say that only me can
create actually.
Then you'll be in trouble.
You're essentially saying that if you'd
never seen something,
it doesn't exist.
No,
I get there.
I'm not saying me personally,
but a sentient objects.
Someone someone has to observe before
possibility become sexuality.
Well,
someone has to make it somewhat.
There's a building,
so we are sort of the quantum
connection,
right?
We have the quantum connection to
consciousness,
nonlocal consciousness all exists,
right?
Right,
but that does not change possibility to
actuality only in the presence of a
concrete observer.
Mostability changes to actually put two
and two together.
So what happens in the presence of an
observer,
Nalco nonlocal consciousness collapses,
gives us our clarity.
Without Observer,
there is no collapsed update possibility
into actuality,
but then look at it from the other angle
without collapsed.
What is the Observer?
There is no concrete.
Brain.
Brain is just a possibility.
This circularity is the key to
understanding who I quantum measurement
can takes place in the brain,
the circularity,
this circular kind of logic.
The circular logic is what manifests
what manifest reality from possibility
it all of these devices like the human
brain or human living or living Celt,
living cell of an Amoeba,
even simpler stock pictures,
all this heavy mysterious entities that
we have theorized about but could not
explain the basic characteristic late
life sanctions.
Now we can understand how they occur.
They occur to quantum measurement
involving the circular logic.
Dark Hofstetter,
who is an artificial intelligence
researcher,
wrote a marvelous book in 1988 called
Godel Escher,
Bach in this book,
conductor.
These circular logical systems as
tangled hierarchies,
so as surprising as it sounds to joe and
I'll just throw out to you,
brain has a tangled hierarchy within it.
This is a specialty and because it has
that,
it is capable of experiencing
consciousness as being the subject.
It captures the subject of
consciousness.
Consciousness identifies with the brain
and brain.
When the brain is involved in the
measurement process,
we who are carrying that brain will say,
I look,
I'm looking at the electronic just as
you will brain looking at me.
So I'm looking at Ahmed as I'm looking
at Joe.
Where does that come from?
Before the measurement,
we are just consciousness,
nonlocal consciousness and possibilities
within it.
I understand that,
but I also understand that although I've
never been to downtown Detroit,
it's real dudes have been there to take
pictures.
In fact,
people built it and they wrote books
about it,
so I don't have to go there to
experience it as an observer to know
that it exists.
Someone,
someone has,
someone had to,
if everybody and try to all of the
sudden just fall asleep including all
sentient creatures,
then there will be no concrete detroit.
That does not mean that they.
When the truck comes to life again comes
to our consciousness again,
as objects,
it will become a different detroit.
No changes don't occur that fast.
You remember the waves of possibility
are very sluggish for macroscopic
objects,
so they try to capture will appear at
the same place,
at the same colors,
the same houses,
the same streets and all of that.
Except that mistake occurs in thinking
that is always there.
It's there.
I still am not understanding how the
human consciousness could be measured or
proven to be nonlocal when the brain,
what we believe is the center of all
this activity
that we equate the consciousness.
This is a very effected if it's shut
off,
if it's damaged and know that it affects
consciousness profoundly.
So what is,
what is the basis for believing that
this consciousness is not proven
theories.
I'm out just asking like what?
Let's turn our light.
What we're really saying.
So I at the brain make it a presentation
of that consciousness that we are
calling nonlocal.
So you build a picture of what it is.
Same for everybody.
It's like,
think of it as the,
you know,
you have seen our archipelago,
right?
The island stand out over the ocean,
but underneath all the islands are
connected.
So think of as connected by this
overarching nonlocal consciousness,
but then we are also individual brains,
right?
We're making.
Each of us are making a representation
of the consciousness that we call our
subject taught.
I'm a subject to the object,
but I'm an object.
We use the subject so we both have that
as a profit.
How do we know that we are non locally
connected,
so a neurophysiologist or the university
or Mexico,
the verified this.
How do we know?
Well,
let's meditate together.
He said with the idea that we will be
communicating without signals directly
without signals,
so we meditate for 20 minutes.
Then we're sent over to what is called
faraday cages.
The cages are cages chambers,
which are electromagnetically in
pervious.
No electromagnetic wave can go through
the walls of this package,
so you and I are sitting in individual
product pages.
What that means is that we cannot
communicate with any kind of
electromagnetic signals
so you can't send a message,
a text message,
you
cannot send a message,
you can extend an electromagnetic method
thinking,
get it,
nothing can get in,
but we are still meditating with the
idea that somehow we'll communicate
directly without signals and now are
both of our brains that are connected to
individual eeg machines,
electroencephalogram,
Mr.
brainwaves and one of the subjects is
shown a series of light flashes that of
course will produce electrical activity
in the occipital area of the brain and
the brain web operators,
the Ge will pick it up,
have heard it.
It appears in time come in in a graph
which is called a evoked potential.
When we extract the signal out of all
the brainwaves,
eliminating the noise so far,
no surprise.
The other subject is not fun.
This is what the surprises,
so please listen carefully.
The other subject is not shown.
A series of light flashes,
no light process at all.
The other subject is connected with
first subject only via this intention
meditation.
We will have direct communication.
So how do you know direct communication
has occurred?
The brain with some this subject not
exposed to light waves,
just brainwaves of this subject was
vegetating basically are picked up from
the electrodes.
We were a machine connected to that
brain and then analyzed in exactly the
same way.
Eliminate the noise,
extract the signal.
The two signals extracted,
one from a subject who has seen light
flashes,
one promise object which has not seen
light flashes.
The tool can be extracted potentials.
One is the evoke potential.
The other one's called transferred
potential.
They overlap almost exactly like 70
percent overlap is often the same.
Eighty percent overlap of on sale.
It's amazing.
They'll not only have the same strength
but also the same place.
So explain to the layman this,
this,
this.
They're experiencing light flashes.
The only one is experiencing one.
One is experience land,
not just the other one.
One is all right,
but the other one is has a reaction in
his mind,
his brain and new way.
No,
the light flashes
reaction in his brain anyway,
which shows that the effect of the light
flashes electrical activity somehow
without signals has been transferred
from one brain to the other.
Why was it then?
I'm assume that consciousness is
nonlocal fat for we.
We say that the two brains are on
locally connected.
Han locally connected on locally
connected Matrix is what we call
consciousness.
Isn't it possible though that the mind
is where consciousness is stored,
but yet it communicates mountain locally
with other minds and other consciousness
that are also stored in people's brains
and that the consciousness is in the
brain and that the non locality is just
the connection?
No,
they were.
They were making,
making not quite considerable scenes
parties.
That's not inconceivable.
That not comfortable,
but I'll tell you if I suppose you
imagine,
imagine consciousness to be contained in
a brain.
Imagine consciousness content in the
sprain and the district,
but what are you saying?
You were saying that my India team,
you're just.
You're just
inventing another word
to convert the notion that there is a
nonlocal matrix.
You want to call it mind.
I want to call it consciousness.
That's the only difference.
Okay,
because look,
there is a brain here that his brain
here normally to loan it,
to say that rain involved something
else.
What brain?
False brain contents.
Those are words we can give but not
necessary.
Here is the brand.
Here's the brain.
Somehow they are communicating right
without any signals because signal could
not pass through the faraday cage
without any signal.
This brain and this brain are
communicating,
communicating by like quiet,
communicating with the transfer of
actual electrical potential that is
measurable by physical experiments,
so nothing like mental telepathy,
physical,
physical transfer of something,
physical transfer of energy without any
legal transfer of a reaction,
not in a physical,
physical transfer of information that
puts that not energy,
no energy actually goes from one to the
other,
but the brains change in such a way that
is obvious.
The synchrony in the way this brand
changed,
but this brand changed because light
flashes fall under that brain.
This brain changing not because of light
flashes,
but because this brain is associated
with this meditative awareness.
That's the case.
Then wouldn't it do you justice to get
as far away from a city as possible
because aren't you constantly
communicating with all the minds in your
city and if if they're all in a good
headspace,
that's great,
but if not,
aren't you experiencing the crazy light
flashes of a million neighbors?
The possibilities are there.
They saving how far away can you get
them filled in at the top of the
mountain,
positive to have that much brain action
around you.
Yeah.
Especially if they're smart and does not
need to be so much scared.
I mean,
it's true that some of that may very
well be true in the emotional domain.
I actually believed that it is somewhat
true,
but actually I believe it's true.
I believe it's.
You could feel it.
Look at football stadium,
we see this,
right.
I mean one guy becomes angry and how
that anger spreads.
That's spread only locally.
Most of the people have not even seen
the anger where it took place,
the gun,
so there could very well be a nonlocal
component in that
kind of thing.
A hive mind that you experienced in
concerts as well.
You know when you watch a concert and
everyone has their hand up in the air
with a lighter and they're all singing
along the journey,
right?
Yeah.
They're locked in there.
Man affects us in a very positive
yes and so but,
but how does that not happen in a
sitting at equilar web?
Because we would go crazy,
there isn't saving guard.
The saving grace is the need for
correlation unless you and I have some
sort of intention that connects us,
we will not be privileged to communicate
to this nonlocal consciousness
essentially saying so,
uh,
in,
in less we have some sort of context to
put it into our own lives.
It doesn't affect us as information
quantum physics.
It gives it more exactly correlation.
We need to be correlated like that in
the,
in the experiment that I just described,
which by the was performed first by a
neuro physiologist named Bell Greenberg
at the list of Mexico.
But,
but that,
that kind of thing,
uh,
you know,
his experiment dependent crucially on
this conscious meditative intention.
Um,
but people can get correlated simpler
than that.
Like in a football stadium.
People are getting correlated just by
simply the identification with the team
that,
that can correlate people on the
Internet.
We never see people,
but we are correlated because we are
some cause that brings us together.
So there are many ways to get
correlated.
And then if people,
once they become correlated certain
things,
I believe that,
uh,
it's easier to transfer emotions than
actual talks and the trail,
we don't correlate very well because
talk rational and restaurant,
it takes us away from this nonlocal
consciousness.
But when we are emotional,
then this nonlocal consciousness can
correlate us and the effects can travel
much better.
This is why one person,
bad mood can get another person to bad
mood or one person's happiness can be
communicated to another person's
happiness.
Happiness is most certainly infectious.
Well,
one of the reasons why comedy clubs work
better,
you know,
laughter becomes infectious when
everyone around you is laughing at,
well,
they'll have your laughing.
Meditation today is taking off like
wildfire in some places.
Laughing.
Meditation,
I think meditation.
I went to India recently,
Bangalore and they have parks,
you know,
where people gather together every
morning,
like at six,
6:30,
and they will have this lafitte
vegetation.
It's,
it's wonderful thing to watch and you
watch your self will start laughing.
That's funny.
You just tickle each other or no,
without thinking like this is the thing.
Well,
part of it of course is is local
communication,
no denying it,
but that jokes and then just the way you
just start laughing.
It was just started laughing and it was
supposed to love so everybody just.
But you know,
you could not maintain that kind of
thing for very long.
If anything,
the mouth muscles will be tired and so
forth.
But here,
because of that nonlocal correlation,
which comes into play after awhile,
you can see more than what you'd expect
just imitating other people to laugh.
Wow,
that's fascinating.
So these people,
how many of them meet?
Oh,
like 50 people,
maybe 50 people in.
They just get together and just laugh
for how long work for 20 minutes.
Just howling.
Well,
it is kind of a very,
very amusing.
Wow.
If you forgive me,
I still don't understand how that makes
consciousness nonlocal I understand that
there's communication,
I that there's sort of a shared
laughing meditation,
this kind of thing,
the experiments you were talking about
it,
this kind of thing.
Something unusual happens.
It's not very difficult to show Deidre
who is a psychologist working at the
Institute of noetic sciences.
Dean Radin does the following
experiment.
He takes what is called random number
generators.
These things are devices in which
radioactive decay is that taking place
because are completed and as you know
already activity the quantum process.
Completely random.
Radioactive.
Say that again.
Ready?
What the activity is a quantum process.
Completely random.
Random decay have taken place.
These random decay is a process by
computer to generate random airways of
zeros and ones.
So they are called random number
generators,
right?
I've heard of this so.
So we have random already supposedly,
and there'll be some deviation from
randomness which can be calculated.
The rule sub statistics gives you that,
but rather than have the tremendous
insight of taking these machines to
meditative places,
I don't know if he has actually done
this with loving meditators,
but he quit.
And what I'm saying is that in the
presence of meditative pupil,
this random number generators start
behaving Nanda randomly.
Nanda,
I'm normally quite way beyond what the
predicted deviation should be.
So were they concentrating on specific
numbers to be generated once and it
should have,
you should have one.
Did they concentrate on specific one
group on zero,
one group on?
No,
they didn't do anything.
We're just meditating,
just meditating,
just keep dating.
And how
perfect.
Uh,
the,
the random number generator did numbers
degenerate.
They're not so random anymore,
right?
There's more zeros done one.
Well wouldn't that.
In fact,
I mean the whole idea of quantum leaping
and quantum teleportation,
meaning that distance really isn't an
issue,
right?
Yeah.
This is not an issue.
So why is it that with these people
meditating in the room with all this
jazz,
that it affects it.
Whereas I would assume anytime you run a
random number generator,
there's someone meditating somewhere in
the world,
probably massive groups of them.
How could the effect of just a couple
individuals vary that much from the
great.
Hi,
very,
very intelligent question.
But remember I also taught,
told about another factor.
People have to be coordinated so that
local correlation is important.
Now,
if you correlate and then look for this
affects,
send people away and they're still
demand correlated because they are
meditating,
then that should work if,
uh,
if you set up a group of meditators but
not in Los Angeles but in Los Angeles,
San Francisco and New York,
but they all are correlated in some ways
by telephone or by internet or some
intention given by a common source,
ones are correlated and they start
meditating.
Distance should not matter.
Okay,
so what essentially what you're saying
is their energy focused on this one
thing can now be measured.
Whereas if their energy is not focused
on it,
it doesn't have an effect on it and the
focusing on the thing has an effect and
the poker thing has been tension.
If we translate the word forecasting to
intention,
then I would agree with focusing is too
general and Sunday the complete notion.
It's something like focusing.
The intention is focusing.
That to me,
if,
if it's truly measurable,
definitely shows are some effect that
the mind has to accept that they weren't
mind.
We use two different consciousness.
Consciousness.
Consciousness is happening,
effect,
but I still.
I don't know how that
keeps you.
Oh,
from.
I mean,
I don't know how that makes
consciousness being nonlocal.
Oh,
it
how you communicate.
Our picture is very simple like this.
You and I had transferred.
Potential electrical activity was
transferred from my brain to your brain
without an electrical connection.
The connection is nonlocal.
No question,
right?
You're not having any difficulty with
that.
That's just how do we interpret it to
interpret it.
How could this happen?
How could this happen is because you.
Although we have not been exposed to
these light flashes now,
but you have in your brain memory of
seeing light flashes,
you have seen light fascist many times
in your life and it's because we're
correlated and no,
no,
because you have seen them before.
So out of this memories,
which are all unconscious processes,
by the way,
whenever you are vegetating,
the unconscious brain,
unconscious,
unconscious because sub his brain stuff
and become.
They become the subjects of the objects
of the unconscious for processing.
So unconscious always has these memories
to process.
That's an interesting point.
Then what happens if you do an
experiment where one person experiences
something that they have no background
in,
I've never seen before.
Most people don't know,
nor does the other person in the room
who's going to receive the signal.
How does he process in that case,
be very difficult.
Things done memory based on the brain.
Memory exists.
Understanding what consciousness is
choosing from that.
So how did,
how did shitty way to communicate?
Nope,
not at all.
Because what a marvelous book.
You have to have memory of it though,
but most things,
most things that we think about help,
most things,
they are exposed
to have memories of it.
I mean how,
how many new things?
Completely new things to do.
Get exposed in a day.
I will say with this dude on a weekend
and exposed to new shits on,
but grill is zero because that will be
at least something coming.
I understand that there's communication.
What I do not understand the finding.
Give the name
what is,
how is this memory being actualized in
your brain
as that cost or some sort of transfer of
information,
but not even a good one.
No,
wait,
is it always on?
Wait a minute.
Remembered being quantum physics
thinking classically again.
Okay.
I'm sorry your Tanya.
I'm being quantum physics Newtonian
unfortunately,
but that is the problem.
We are all Newtonian when we are not
using subtle language so you have to get
used to it.
I understand your brain is possibility
unconsciously just giving you
possibility.
So unless this entity called
consciousness is choosing possibility,
it will not have the actual transport
potential.
Okay,
so how can you have it transferred?
Potential you potential being
transferred by a nonlocal meet Matrix
that we're calling consciousness because
it has to be consciousness who chooses
out of the possibilities of your brain
generated by previous memory because you
are meditating with your partner and the
partner has seen this light flashes
consciousness by virtue of that
correlation is choosing from your
unconscious which has the memory,
but nothing more than that has the
possibility,
but nothing more than that,
no actuality,
but consciousness is choosing the
actuality because you are meditating to
receive that.
Sir,
I'm going to have to disagree with you.
This is why I understand what you're
saying.
I completely do,
but I don't think it necessarily means
that your consciousness is non local,
can make an alternative model.
This doesn't have to be an alternative
model.
Just the idea of communication and only
through through information being passed
forth where what you're measuring is so
like imprecise the.
You're saying 70 percent,
right?
No,
no,
no.
Nothing in precise.
Okay.
There's some sort of a signal being
transferred between one person,
another separate papers happened to
percentage.
Huge.
I'll tell you when,
and
you don't meditate when you don't
meditate.
Right.
The potential up.
The other person is vegetating is
practically nothing,
so there's no transfer whatsoever.
Adrenaline's meditating.
If you don't meditate,
the never found.
They never found any turn for potential,
but whenever they would meditate,
all of a sudden there is the electric
potential which is like 70 percent,
80 percent,
60 percent of the detect if a potential.
There is something here.
Cool.
There's something being transferred
weekends without.
Without any signal.
I totally appreciate
matrix between the two people.
I'm just giving it a name.
That metrics we call consciousness,
right?
Because what is happening in the.
In the.
In the two people consciousness,
remember the vehicle to know it,
so what is happening is that something
is being transferred which has no basis
for the transfer.
Transfer takes energy that is already
usually experienced here is transfer,
taking place without any energy
transfer,
without any signal transfer,
holding the understanding because the
possibility of that is already there in
the other brain and consciousness is
choosing the possibility and making it
actual.
How is
is that any different than distributing
information?
How is it any different than one person
has an experience and relays that
experience through information to the
other person,
cannot local signals through something,
some sort of a connection?
Yeah,
look at signals that even but not like
sound signals are being able to
communicate.
I mean in the meditative state,
ics exchanging information.
If it is not local thickness than it is
consciousness only.
Now you got to getting it.
You're just objecting to language,
but
does the person who is sitting in the
other room who's receiving these
signals,
do they have a memory of this?
If there's,
is there a cognitive impact?
Devastate definite signal that I'm
detecting for this brain.
Does the person aware of it who detects
it?
The patient there is no cognitive
mission and the other person because the
brain is so complex,
unless you focus on something that we
will never,
we have not yet been able to isolate a
cognitive change and the person.
See that's where I'm having a hard time
making the leap between what I
understand to be a clear sense of some
sort of a communication,
but how does that mean that all
consciousness is long,
non local?
How does that not mean some real new
form of communication that is evolving
inside the human body
already got the language.
I'm sorry,
but I mean no,
it's that new form.
Exactly right.
Am I getting Newtonian?
Did I go Newtonian on,
Ya know,
if Tony,
they send you a farmer saying that it's
but it's rudimentary right now.
I'm just giving it a name.
Okay.
You agreed that there is something.
If you're telling me,
you're telling me I'm.
I don't understand any of this.
I agree that in your story and your
story and your experience,
sorry you all many times and
factually during this broadcast,
without signals at times for up
information or transfer of
you have put the electric potential
completely based on your story.
I mean,
spending mental data.
I don't mean the story.
That's a bad word for it.
I have your information that you're.
You're presenting experimental data to
in 2011.
Birth order is in different parts of the
world,
what we call this matrix of times times
far up signals.
Yes.
East Ohio had our differences.
That's what I'm saying is that it is.
If you look at the rest of our theory,
because it takes consciousness.
Anything information.
So we call this matrix consciousness.
Hmm.
Okay.
And in fact the person is receiving it
on the other end.
Even though consciousness is non local,
the other person isn't even conscious.
They're receiving it.
If you want to look at it that way or
cognizant
that would not fit help.
Hey,
let's put the experiment.
Remember people already have data,
extensive data up telepathy.
What's the most convincing data of
telepathy that you've experienced?
I have myself experienced,
uh,
or,
or that you know,
again,
it's subjective,
so people up to object,
but,
uh,
this,
these experiments called distant
experiments have been done viewing
remote viewing.
It now done so accurately analyze by
computers.
You were looking at a town square at the
statue.
Your coordinated person coordinated by
the international export export and
metric is sitting in the closet in the
laboratory.
He's just drawing a picture of the
structure that you're looking at it.
Nobody knows what you're looking at.
A computer has chosen who it will go to
look at the statute at computer,
unbeknownst to everyone connected with
the experiment is analyzing the picture
that with your coordinator friend,
psychic is drawing of what you're
looking at and then computer is bringing
the two together,
the picture of the statute that they are
actually looking at and the picture that
the person has drawn.
Computer does the matching and computer
says,
Hey,
there is 90 percent match between this.
This could not be just a happenstance,
this,
this got to be a transfer of
information.
Got To be an example of telepathically.
What is some studies specifically have
shown remote viewing tie to be that
accurate?
Is there anything that you could just
for the folks listening?
Yeah.
That day said Russell targeted Harold
put off,
started this kind of experiment.
Uh,
in 19 seventies.
Yeah.
Russell Targ is actually coming on the
podcast.
He's,
he's going to be on in April.
Yeah.
I put,
yeah,
he was one of the pioneers.
So distracted this and 19 slash 70,
a 73,
74 if I remember it right.
And he and her all put off his partner.
They did a lot of this in Sri Stanford
Research Institute.
And um,
what the new thing is that these are,
the analysis is done much by very
objectively.
It's no longer subject,
but even then materialist object to it
because it's,
it's still the mind,
but in the experiment that I gave you,
transport potential experiment of our
Greenberg,
nobody can object because it is not.
Mine is not involve.
Actually cognitive cognition got
involved.
People immediately start saying,
well,
it's subjective,
but here they transfer.
That actually isn't the objective domain
material.
Measurable Material in measurable
electric potential here in material,
in measurable electric potential there
in between.
No local connection and therefore the
proof.
Actually in this experiment,
the transport potential experiment is
the most accurate proof of nonlocality
than you ever saw.
So that means that there's a connection
that we don't know about that has always
existed between human beings constantly.
And the only thing that's missing is the
intention and the focus on the two
right now it's stated it complete.
Accurate
is.
I'm sorry.
Is this something that you think as we
have evolved from lower primates to
human beings,
is this something that is beginning to
show its potential in the human species
is something that might improve and
expand
if you'll believe other experimental
data that people have been collecting
since the early fifties or sixties.
Like,
um,
the name of that fellow Baxter,
I forget his first name.
Clyde Baxter.
That makes them make.
Make A.
I can look it up for you.
Clyde Baxter,
Baxter Baxter's,
the last name that I know.
He did some experiments with
communication with plants,
communication with plants.
So no,
that was,
that was one of the earliest experiments
and there are others.
So it's not just humans.
Plants have that ability.
Probably even Amoeba has that ability,
but at a very rudimentary.
Yeah.
His name was Claude.
It's cleaved c l e
Baxter,
Baxter.
Okay.
Lax for hell kind of name is that,
but great experiment.
You discarded that much,
but now we understand that.
No,
because I could really be something in
his experiments.
Yeah.
That is absolutely fascinating that
there's a perception between animals and
he did it using a polygraph machine.
Yeah.
Here's your.
He was polygraphed is shit by Rupert.
Sheldrake is the latest.
One of the latest trends in this.
He is showing that dogs communicate
telepathically with their masters.
Yeah.
I heard about this and I've also heard
some other things.
Rupert sheldrake has said recently,
something about the speed of light
varying,
which a lot of people are coming down on
him for that.
It's a bad science and pseudoscience at
best.
I have that.
Yeah.
I haven't seen that either,
but there are people in my message where
we're going bananas about him because
he's a very controversial character in
the first place because if,
if what he says is true,
like the amazing randy is always
offered,
I think it's a million dollars for
anybody can prove any sort of psychic
connection.
Why hasn't anybody taking that guy up
on.
Because he doesn't pay.
He doesn't pay and pitch because he
always finds like,
you know,
it can always object.
Notice the 70 percent times,
but I 100 percent.
Is that what he does?
I don't know what he does,
but he will not pay anybody looked at
this kind of situation.
You can always raised some objection to
everything.
Has there ever been a study that you've
seen on these dogs knowing that their
masters are coming on this trip
movie after movie is made a movie of
this and I saw the movie.
It has to marketplace.
I know him.
I'm a good friend of his actually.
So my wife and I went to his house and
he showed us a movie of the dog and also
the parrot parrots.
He has shown also can communicate
telepathically with their master's.
Oh,
it's amazing it dog movie.
I remember very clearly.
The dog is waiting in the house.
He and his regular sitting place is the
software.
That's why as soon as the master lives,
he loves her.
He jumps on the Sofa and invest there.
You know it.
They love human warmth,
warming up the sofa,
the particular place where to master
satin.
They'll stay there,
so is there and 5:00
comes right.
Master is now getting up from her desk
and the dog jumps and comes through the
window.
It's time and time again.
He has photograph the dog and
photographs in muster,
so dogs are becoming aware as soon as
the master is ready to come home and
that awareness is shown by the dog
jumping down at that exact time,
as master gets up from her desk,
his guest to come home,
it's amazing.
He's done it multiple times,
multiple times of it,
and always using cameras in both places
in synchrony and always exactly at that
time.
The dog will react and if they've
mastered,
does not get up from the desk dog will
not get up from his sofa either.
So it takes quite amazing responses.
So what I said,
why doesn't just collect that million?
No,
I would say I feel like that's,
you know,
if you got that concept is called
morphic resonance,
is that not,
this is,
he will not bring morphic resonance for
discipline metrics.
Part of transforming people's learning.
That's a,
that's a slightly different thing.
You learned something.
It's stored in the morphic morphic
fields,
morphogenetic fields.
And then um,
if I,
I might be able to get this
morphogenetic fields to communicate to.
Yeah.
I,
the,
the concept I thought was kind of
related because his uh,
his,
he deals in an interconnectivity sort of
a way to with this.
Well,
he believes that if animals have
animals,
like every species have a certain sort
of a database almost.
And then if rats in St Paul learn how to
get through a maze,
the same rats in Florida,
we'll be able to get through a quicker.
Yeah.
But this kind of thing has to be taken
with a grain of salt.
That does.
Yeah.
And all the crazy shit we've talked
about that has to be taken with a grain
of salt.
Yeah.
Because the transfer is occurring to
this,
this pills.
The morphogenetic field.
It,
it,
it may not transfer in exactly that form
is what I'm.
What I'm saying is that the.
Originally what happened was people
started this kind of thinking because an
experiments seem to have done this
experiment.
Real experiment was that the,
uh,
in an island,
some monkeys learn a monkey model.
That's how it started.
And monkey mother learned to wash her
sweet potato before eating.
And she found that the test improves
much.
So she immediately talked to her
offspring.
So the baby monkeys are also learning
that.
And then the entire island of monkeys
learn to sweet potatoes before eating.
Somehow this was the data untopological
data.
I've looked at the paper and the
original journal,
but when somehow somebody reported on
this data in a book that somebody
invented an extension which never
happened,
which is that in monkeys in a nearby
island without any connection picked up
the same,
so it's a lie.
It was based on next saturation.
Very Fun motherfuckers researchers that
exaggerate.
That's a dangerous.
That's a dangerous habit.
Exaggerated.
This is not a restructuring.
Comedians exaggerated,
but it's funny,
Dan,
unfortunately communicators exaggerate
communicators,
etc.
Because we are used to attract
attention.
Yes.
Anything for the sake of attention,
so mayBe they just wanted to get funding
for their research.
Not that way.
No researcher exaggerated.
It's the only the communicators,
they thing that the book will sell more.
If I say something I understand.
I would
assume that something like animals
washing their food if human beings.
I mean the word evolution is a very
touchy subject amongst people when it
comes to natural selection and the
advancement of the species,
but it's commonly knowledged
scientifically that we were once
primitive organisms and that's all that
was on the planet.
If that is the case,
the intelligent animals like chimpanzees
or monkeYs or whatever,
they would,
I would assume that much like people
slowly all over the world figured out
how to make tools with rocks,
that monkeys would slowly figuring out
new things.
CAt
litter.
Yeah.
They themselves.
no,
I'm just saying that cats are born just
knowing how to use the cat litter box.
It's in there.
Yeah,
exactly.
That's why they never get smart enough.
Thank you for pointing that out.
exactly.
It's interesting because you are right
and do it right,
because it is true that lots of things
don't get transferred.
So in philly,
and it is also true that there are this
a case of instinct,
right?
There was some transparent stop,
that kind of thing that universally
everybody has picked up within.
Then what's your feeling on epigenetics?
The idea that that epigenetics are
related to this morphogenic fields,
so it is not very clear.
Would you explain that to be sure belief
was ever since darwin and after some
verifications of darwin that came apart,
the belief has been that genes are the
only way that any heriditary
characteristics learning can be
transferred to subsequent generations.
That has been the belief right now.
Now though,
there are phenomena which showed that
no,
something else move.
Very well be involved.
One of the striking phenomenon is this
phenomenon of morphogenesis or cell
differentiation.
We all begin as you and I both began as
single celled embryos,
right,
and then that single cell divides itself
divided itself,
making replica itself,
but it is still true that our toast
cells and our brain cells behave very
differently.
Why?
Because the proteins are very different.
Proteins that are made in those cells
are proteins.
Proteins are made because of
instructions written in the gene called
the genetic code,
but the genes ababa all of ourselves at
the same.
So the expansion is that some genes are
activated in the tau proteins and other
genes are activated in the brain making
the brain proteins.
This is why brain cells differ very much
in their activity than the host cells.
Okay.
So far?
Yes.
Alright,
so then this.
How does the cell different sessions
take place?
So people said there must be programs
sub ditto sally's program differently
than the genes of brain cells were sales
and brand sauce that sand banks have
different programs running the but where
are these programs?
Right.
So initially the ability has the program
must also be in the genes.
Now people are seeing that no,
the programs for cell different session,
not in the genes,
they are in the epigenetics outside of
teaching.
So sheldrick originally was suggesting
very something very similar which is
idea of morphogenetic field.
And so if you assume that morphogenetic
fields are they blueprints of biological
form and they are non local,
then there is no way,
no difficulty in explaining why they tow
cells behave very differently in brain
cell.
How does the cell know what to do in a
different way when it is in the
different parts of the body?
If it's in the in the toe,
then those genes to be activated which
can,
which can make protein which can perform
in the way if it's in the brain.
Similarly those genes will be activated
which can make protein which makes it
behave to brain way,
but how are they doing it in all in
synchrony because of this nonlocal
morphogenetic field that is involved,
so in a way epigenetics is the first
step of verification of shelter.
Next idea.
The next step is taken by a biologist
like bruce lipton who are saying that
well,
quantum practice,
certain balled in biology and safe
quantum processes involved in our
consciousness based quantum measurement
theory is telling us that consciousness
must be involved in this way.
We can.
We now can understand the whole gamut of
ideas that leads to these things.
And finally to connect up what you are
just saying.
These instincts,
so certain learning from the past to get
passed on.
So the belief is tech specific,
some specific type of learning which
involves emotions.
My guess is that if the learning's
involves emotional,
has an emotional aspect,
then probably the morphogenetic fields
are easier to transfer the certain
innate involving peers and similar
emotions,
egotism and suck even racism,
racism,
this kind of thing.
But what if it is purely cerebral mental
than it is probably harder to transfer
through morphogenic field.
That morphogenetic field transfer is a
pretty fairly good idea and you have to
find some explanation of the instincts
that it did get transferred in
windstream.
Start universal.
So we have a very peculiar situation.
Instincts could not possibly be
explained by genetics.
Many people have written about this
saturday,
difficult to understand on the basis of
genes.
So if you'll bring morphogenetic field
to understand the instinct,
then you get the idea that yes,
we can,
we can today become a nicer person,
have brain circuits of um,
uh,
love.
ANd then a few generations later via the
transference morphogenetic field,
everybody will begin to have circuits of
loving their pain.
Well,
you bring up a really interesting point
because,
um,
the,
the chemical composition of a,
of the mind,
all the different serotonin and dopamine
and neurotransmitters and all the
different things that are going on
inside the mind,
it will alter those and one way or
another,
positive or negative and you get
profound effects on how the person
behaves and thinks and interfaces with
their reality.
How do you feel persoNally about the all
the different pills that people are on
and all the different pills that,
that alter consciousness.
It seems a very strange time when we are
doing so much experimentation on a,
on a daily basis,
altering the way a person's mind is a,
is interfacing with its reality and
we're see profound effects.
a lot of people don't know.
NInety percent of school shooters either
were on antidepressants,
had been on them and we're on
withdrawal.
Ninety percent is a big number.
I mean,
it doesn't prove that that's what caused
it because a lot of times these people
are depressed and guess what?
People were depressed.
Getting on antidepressants.
It doesn't mean that it caused them to
be psychotic or to have psychotic
breaks,
but there is something to be,
there's,
there's something to be studied for
sure.
Well,
it's very dangerous to put the natural
brain under tracks of any kind,
especially those drugs which are
psychoactive because you don't ever know
strategies there.
So scanty,
uh,
you don't even know what the effects are
and how the effects will be specialty
longterm effects.
And,
and,
and what we do know is that depression
is now the third biggest epidemic
disease.
It's almost epidemic,
but besides heart disease and cancer,
depression is the third most common
chronic disease who I.
Is it because depression depends so much
on these brain chemicals and of course
so much also on how we process our
stuff,
emotions thinking.
So something is basically going wrong in
the,
in the,
in the new theory,
um,
wherever we talk in terms of chakras,
because all the places where they're
very much involved with our emotions,
the emotion that is involved in the
highest place in our body,
the neocortex,
emotions that are involved with
specifically our,
what we call satisfaction.
So If neocortex dIsplayed with certainly
it will affect our level of
satisfaction.
By the same token,
people might be using antIdepressant to
better suit your level of satisfaction.
You know what happens when you take
prozac,
you get sort of,
you get temporarily,
it will get to get,
get to look at the world as okay,
you're getting a feeling of,
okay,
they're satisfied so people are using
things like that to give them a feeling
of satisfaction because it's not there
in the absence of taking this drug
prozac,
so in this way,
but we don't know the consequence of
taking prozac and a good brain longterm
consequences of it.
I am terribly,
terribly upset about the drug culture
because we're getting into stuff.
Does every device that we need that is
intimately connected with our
consciousness,
our brain that is no manifest
consciousness.
We have to recognize that to play with
that vehicle,
which gives us the basic way of
cognition,
basic way of experiencing everything
that we know.
Conversely though,
I have met people that have some sort of
an imbalance,
they have some sort of a chemical
balance in the mind and I have
personally seen people take medication
and it's benefited them,
greatly improved,
but there's that,
but then there's also people that just.
They're not living a fulfilling life
there.
They don't have good friendships,
relationships,
job opportunities that they're not
pursuing the career they really wanted
to impress for good reason to be
depressed and a lot of times with that
depression is is in fact the world
around you and how your body is
perceiving it in the negative energy
that you're getting and feeling about
it.
It's supposed to motivate you to change,
supposed to motivate you to move away
from it.
The negative feelings that you have
after any personal altercation with
someone,
those are supposed to be like,
that's to let you know,
hey,
whatever you just did,
don't fucking do that anymore.
Okay,
whatever.
However you interacted with the person
that created this terrible wave of bad
feelings,
it's not satisfying.
It's not satisfying to you and you can't
just take a pill executive to change
that,
but the way to where to where to took
kinds of situation involved here and the
brain,
the device itself may have wrong
neurochemicals and therefore we get the
satisfaction.
We get depression or it can be that the
psychological effect of stuff that's
producing the depression.
If it is the the latter psychological
stuff that producing dissatisfaction.
Then actually in a way it's easier
because we can use psychological method.
In fact,
we should.
I am not in favor of using brain
chemicals like prozac to reestablish the
balance.
If the cost is psychological,
if the call is coming from genetics or
family history are,
are clear brain dysfunction,
brain imbalance,
then it should be treated with what
brain chemicals with,
with,
with madison.
But If it is psychologically caused,
it's better to try to improve the
satisfaction level of the person and
when we can,
we can by bringing in the heart chakras,
starting with the heart chakra where
love resides.
Then expression where,
um,
which decides and the throat chakra and
then podcasting which resides in the
tardive or in between the two brows,
brow chakra,
and then of course the crown chakra in
the neocortex,
which is the seat of satisfaction so we
can improve satisfaction by
concentrating not so much on the lord
emotions,
which is the lower chakras there.
The emotions that you get are all those
fear and sexuality and price.
Sexuality low
or know,
I thought it was way up there.
It's in a sense because it's a doorway
to something where of have to love.
So sex is actually a very special one
because if used in moderation,
sex is actually a very good one because
it's the doorway to love.
It's one doorway.
I've always thought that I always got
pissed off at monks that don't have sex
coming sexist.
This is why we call effing make love,
right?
Watching.
It can.
You can,
you can do it the effort or you can do
it.
Making law.
The cost point,
is that what you.
The way we use it,
so sexist,
kind of good and bad both.
I mean all of this actually good and
bad.
Both fear is also good sometimes because
it takes us away from danger.
You go test.
The movement is good sometimes because
it gives us assurance.
Self assurance,
so used in moderation and negative
emotions are okay.
It's one day.
Go out of control.
Then there are problems.
Positive emotions are good all the time,
little or more.
Love is not going to kill you.
Love is only going to elevate you so you
can never have too much love.
So in this way,
if we learn to concentrate more on this
positive emotions,
we could actually heal or psychological.
He caused cases of depression
psychologically caused cases of
depression and that's where you have to
differentiate,
correct.
You have to differentiate between people
who are depressed because they're in a
bad state in life and people who are
depressed because the mind's not working
correctly and there are two,
and this is not work.
The real issue is the overdiagnosis than
or at least the overprescription of
prescribing psychologists tend to do
because it's easy to treat the
brain chemicals.
The chemical psychologist try to get
away with just using drugs because the
effect will be quicker.
I think if we use an integration of both
approaches,
why they do quicker because it's.
Have you ever lived with a mentally ill
person is difficult.
It's very difficult,
so parents,
of course one immediate cure,
so best strategy probably is to use
antidepressants immediately because that
will give a temporary healing,
but of course the psychological
residents who will be president so it
will come back,
it will continue,
and then they start the psychological
treatment that I'm suggesting,
which are already people are suggesting
I shouldn't take the original credit for
it,
nothing like that,
but this dealing with noble emotions,
how are emotions?
Positive emotions that healing will take
time.
Prozac can give us time for the prospect
can buy us time so we can use a
combination of both conventional and the
new medicine mind body medicine
suggestion.
This is what I suggested is called mind
body medicine because you're trying to
heal the brain in balance with the
effect of the mind.
The health.
I'll do mine.
There seems to be a real issue with
modern humans too,
and that the life that we live does not
really satisfy all of our natural reward
systems that we have in place.
The hunter gatherer systems and sitting
in a cubicle and and you know,
and all of it,
even monogamy is a struggle for a lot of
people for,
for that very reason is that we have a
lot of genetics that are set up from a
different time and they're still in our
system
and we have not talked to.
We have not taught very well.
We don't been up and taught how to
manage it.
We're not being taught how to manage it
correctly.
Yeah.
That's a very important,
very important.
Why isn't that one of the most important
things that you could teach a child is
how to,
how to manage them
back to,
uh,
you know,
educational reform is so needed,
so needed part.
Another thing,
you know,
how do you,
how do you bring this stuff to a child?
You have to use creativity,
obviously conditioning that.
Their body is conditioned in a certain
way since the days of hunter gatherers.
Those conditioning are still present.
Mine has moved onto restaurant wind.
Look at the predicament of us learning
today because some of our conditioning
of the body,
the remains the same as the hunter got
that or nothing has changed,
but the mind has moved onto purely
dealing with mine.
Mine does not even deal with the body.
Well,
not only that,
the environment has changed radically to
the environment that your physical
body's interfacing with has changed
radically and those natural reward
systems are not being fun,
not being fed.
So we live in a world where we really
need a new educational system which will
bring this aspect stop and use creative
creativity quite because these things
require creative learning.
What what has to happen is that the
context of our thinking,
which is thinking without the emotions,
this has evolved so much.
you know,
it becomes very cerebral,
tinkers,
only involvement with neocortex.
Instead we can.
We can start involving some of what we
left behind,
some of the emotions that are intuitive.
Some of the emotions that you have not
dealt with and we have to read it
tonight.
It integrate how we think about
emotions,
reintegrate that into our present life
system,
which is more thinking rationally,
who just thinking about thinking itself,
not so much thinking emotional.
It's very frustrating to you as as a,
as a professor for over 32 years,
I believe.
Right?
Is it frustrating to you?
It was until I discovered new ways of
teaching.
I started putting things in an emotional
way because it will get.
you can reframe it.
You don't have to.
when we teach new physics,
for example,
quantum physics versus classical
physics,
classical physics is all study abroad,
but quantum physics,
because it has that aspect of choice I
choose.
Therefore something can happen already
and emotional component can get in
because whenever you say I chose,
you'll find that you're a start chapter,
naval chapter sort of body eagle is
immediately alert.
Those were your ego's a body ego,
not reminding the body.
so that's why people are weirded out
when you poked her belly button.
Okay man,
get off my ego.
There's a bit of that,
uh,
the,
when,
when you feel quite as quite assured of
yourself,
uh,
do you find that navel chakra is find a
quieter teeth?
But yeah,
nice enabled massage cooler,
but why do,
are not feeling?
So I shared butterflies in the stomach.
Oh,
that's interesting.
Very common experience.
That's interesting.
And that's the connection where,
where's the whole soccer thing come
from?
What is that from?
They,
they did.
There was no explanation for a long
time.
Then when the new science,
they have an expedition because then the
new science to introduce this
morphogenetic fields as part of reality.
What are morphogenic fields?
they are the blueprints of biological
origins,
right?
We went to the sell different fashion.
And so neocortex has a blueprInt,
the toes of a different blueprint.
So there's blueprints is the,
is the morphogenetic field.
So in quantum physics we started that
morphogenetic fields and they organs
that then non-locally correlated through
consciousness.
Consciousness operates on one hand,
the blueprints.
On the other hand,
the oregon's chakras are those places
where the organs are present,
the important part of the body.
look at all the chakras.
Every chapter is the site of a very
important organ.
Is there a sexual bro?
Yo,
that's.
What's that one called?
Would that foreign is called sex chakra.
It's called sex chakra.
Thanks.
Check.
Did they work on that one in yoga too?
Is that whether the girl is one of those
tight pants.
So that's all about the course.
But you have golf course has a sanskrit
name of it,
the sanskrit name of it,
but it's pretty complex.
But there is a scientific sort of a
correlation between the shock between
the sex organs and the corresponding
morphogenetic field.
Do you practice yoga yourself?
Yeah,
every day.
It's a good thing.
Not every day because of my travel
schedule,
but most days that I can.
Yes.
And how yoga has been around for
thousands of years and some people will
just dismiss it as simply stretching,
but if you've never actually done it and
I try to tell people,
just go to one of those beat yoga
classes.
Just take one class or or whatever's in
your neighborhood.
Just take one class and then talk.
Because until you do,
you really don't know what that feeling
is like.
That feeling after yoga is your high,
your high a little bit.
You love people.
You want to call people and apologize.
You want to hug people.
I'm telling you,
brian,
you need that shit in your life,
son.
We were definitely high.
What happened?
Is that the best with of the ama
[inaudible] really nice.
Yes.
The energy gets into the crown chakra
satisfaction,
right?
Or in the higher chakras.
Very definitely.
so ground chapter is connected with,
you know,
chronic chapter satisfied.
You get this endorphin molecules that
the byproduct of yoga,
the crown chakra.
So no endorphin molecules are wonderful
if that's the height,
that's the high actually.
So it's fairly simple explanation why we
get decided and why it should not be
trivialized you.
There are many other ways to get high,
but this is one of the best ways because
at the same time your gating,
getting an exercise of the muscles and
joints.
Yes.
And you're stretching and stretching
like a lot of people don't think of you
think of stretching.
It's for athletic performance,
but stretching is also for attention
release.
It's an amazing tension remains.
Yeah,
and because that tension release now
will in the future say you from
february.
Debilitating disease.
Yes,
absolutely.
So good.
PreventIve medicine in a way and
flexibility last is very difficult to
repair,
a difficult to.
It's not that hard to maintain once
you've attained
once you have attended and the key is
not to never to completely discontinue
it.
Even if you can do once a week is better
than not doing it at all.
You know what the problem with yogurt
though?
Fake yoga people.
You know what I'm talking about.
You do people that are claiming to be
spiritual and showing up a yoga classes,
but the really annoying.
Do you know those people?
You do.
Right,
but,
but the point is of course that you
know,
there will always be effect pupil.
There's always going to be bumper
stickers.
All there's
going to be bumper stickers.
You cannot avoid.
This thing is not the real thing because
of the effect.
It's very true and in reality it's a
small percentage of the yoga people that
are fake.
It's a tiny percentage and if you,
and if you think about the general
scammers in the population,
there's always going to be issues with
men in male ego and posturing and
there's always going to be easy.
I mean similar issues with women and
women dealing with other women,
but I,
I've seen the fake yoga man and I've
seen the fake yoga woman.
I'll take the fake yoga woman everyday.
Fake yoga man is trying to get laid.
The fake yoga woman is just trying to be
pretend to be a little more spiritual
and not materialistic than she truly is,
but the fake yoga man,
it's just trying to get laid.
He's annoying
and then maybe one out of 100,
but that's enough that these things.
I think that some people will get into
the new age movement with the idea of
finding relationship,
which in a way of course is finding.
I love how you just put that,
know what they're doing.
they're trying to get some pussy.
There's a big difference between find a
relationship and just
sometimes they tend to be just finding a
one night stand,
which is of course their language is
quite accurate.
Well,
I think it's they're trying to appear
desirable and one of the ways to appear
desirable to women to be introduced,
which is supposed to be spiritual.
Yes.
Yeah.
That's a trick.
That is all true and I'm sure that as
quantum physics,
quantum fakers
fakers,
and I'm not trying to focus entirely on
the negative,
but I'm trying to address what I know
people in the general public,
the issues that they have with,
with folks that claim to be spiritual.
It's like you'll run into a fake yoga
person and you're like,
oh my god,
you know,
either the typically unique guy with his
beads and this is hemp sandals and you
just want to punch them.
Right.
You know what I'm talking about?
Like didn't you have to wait?
You have to be patient looking at the
other side.
Tell you a story,
a typical hinduism teaching story.
Okay.
So if tiff comes to the master spiritual
master and the at the end of the night,
which are master of course stay with me.
No problem.
So the toughest stealing this stuff,
all the whole thing.
So the buster opens the eyes and says,
do you remember,
did you remember to take everything
because you know,
I really don't need that stuff over
there either so you can take that tube.
So tip is caught.
But he's very surprised.
Know master is not throwing him in jail
or the police or anything like that.
So he's become a little curious.
So he lays things down the way or you
not angry because I'm feeling your stuff
right?
I said for most of this stuff,
look,
I don't really need it.
I still have attachments so I keep them.
So if you're taking notes,
okay.
So it beComes a littLe more curious and
it says,
well,
since you don't mind me stealing it
anytime,
why should I have to steal it at the end
of the night?
Let me stay with you for a few days just
watching your metrics and what you do.
Then I'll take them awaY.
At the end of the week,
my son says,
yeah,
fine,
just stay with me,
so it just stays for a few days as he
looks at the master and tries to do some
of the stuff.
He sTarts changing by faking.
Initially he thought you'll just fake
the monster because then he'll pick up
the faking and then his stealing
capacity will increase manifold because
it will impress people by being a
spiritual man.
People will have.
You will have more access to more houses
and he will be able to steal more.
That was the origiNal idea.
This is why you wanted to watch the
master,
but then as It did two things,
meditate and sit and talk to people.
After even a few days it started
changing sodium so it can begin with the
fake and ended up with something else
and of course master knew it all the
time.
So at the end of the seven days,
master says,
okay,
now you take this stuff and leave.
Why are you belonging your stage and the
and the and the fellow calls on the
feed.
That's an indian medium of saying
surrender subsets that,
no,
I want to learn what makes it you.
I'm not interested in stealing the small
stuff anymore.
I want to steal the stuff that you are
made up so it's so where we can make
even use sub this faith is.
It's amazing by being patient with the
people who are faking and just allowing
them in the process because although the
initial intention is superficial,
but as you ruled them,
consumption itself,
consuming this very wonderful stuff,
very wonderful behavior will begin to
give the idea.
Or maybe I can become a producer.
these energies that I faked by
meditating,
if I actualize them,
then they will actually produce changes
in meta profound and um,
which should open the gates for that
rather than closing it by saying,
oh,
you are just a fake instead.
No,
we're a little more tolerant about them.
I am.
I am kind of losing the quantum
language.
Although they have no idea what they're
talking about.
But then,
but then you explain it one time and
they'll become a little curious.
And initially their curiosity will be,
I can pick up a little more and impress
people a little more medevac,
covenantal,
more curious,
more curious.
One day they'll ask,
well,
can I actually start doing this stuff?
And really be creative.
Wow.
Didn't find in one,
said,
if you think you understand quantum
mechanics,
you don't understand quantum mechanics,
uh,
well,
one of them now,
many,
many sayings.
This could come from niels bohr who said
that if we will talk to you,
understood quantum physics,
then probably didn't understand it at
all.
So that many,
many,
many things about quantum physics,
man said something like,
nobody understands quantum physics.
One time he did say something like that.
So why do people say something like
that?
Because quantum physics at some level
becomes so incredibly mysterious that
India,
first of matter consciousness can be
involved.
This is just such a inherent mystery.
Many people are savvy,
heart put to accept this kind of thing.
So they would rather have nobody
understands quantum mechanics then
except that consciousness is needed to
understand quantum mechanics.
So these are the barriers of new
thinking coming into the field of
science.
But you know what,
because experimentally we are verifying
the idea of nonlocal consciousness.
We are verifying the idea that really
eased at nonlocal connection between
people or the way we got knowledge named
the consciousness is actually nonlocal.
that verification will go a long way in
changing the paradigm,
changing the world.
How did yoga get discovered?
How did they figure out that these poses
and stretches could open up your mind
and,
and change your consciousness.
What,
what is,
what is the history behind that?
Well,
the original,
if you read patanjali's yoga sutra,
he just introduced us author yoga as a
way of finding a comfortable place to
meditate.
Originally the idea was just to sit
comfortably and in order to sit
comfortably in meditation for a long
period of time.
Stretching helps,
and then they discovered one very
wonderful thing.
As people meditated the bain job of
meditation,
they found this to create gap between
tots.
You slow down your mental process.
So once they discovered that the idea of
slowing down the mental process helps
enormously,
or creativity or spirituality.
Once they found that out,
then they realized the next wonderful
thing is that isn't yoga also a way of
slowing down.
The body Is in front I a way of slowing
down the breaths and therefore all the
arguments,
so the interest group at your eight
self,
I'll tell you a gauge self is not just
stretching or just working on the
joints.
It's also weird to slow down the body
and therefore the mind is alternately it
indirectly slowing down the wind because
if the body is slow,
wind will also be slow
by focusing on the poses and your breath
in your throat.
Not so much like bikram Yoga,
fast yoga,
but in the original way that you've
done.
That's quite slow.
The slow yoga is actually even better
than the first year,
but not at the festival.
Loses everything of yoga festival is
also good,
but they'd be even better because it
slows down.
The body slows down,
the mind slows down.
The vital energies slows down our
emotions.
It gives you a lot of breaths between
your fast,
fast,
fast go,
go,
go mind,
and especially important for developing
creativity because creativity is
enormously dependent on that unconscious
processing,
doing nothing,
do and be so.
If we do yoga regularly,
we really don't differ.
Need meditation or goodwill day,
we can just do yoga and get the benefit
on the mind from yoga,
lower that that is goes a long way for
our creativity.
There's a lot of ancient texts that
connect yoga with cannabis,
use yoga with how she shoes and and and
even eating cannabis.
Are you familiar with this?
you're now familiar with.
Oh,
look aT you.
Your slide devil with that smile on your
face.
Someone's got a reputation to maintain
and no,
I don't really know that.
From that point of view.
Do you have any experience at all in a
psychedelic?
I do.
A little less certain tried.
I've been in this faith if it's not
against the law to what do you mean?
Marijuana?
Yes.
You have to take a very mild or atlanta.
So I was going to ask you about some
mild in one time and one time what it's
about samsung or something very
familiar.
I'll look at your old school devil.
Exactly.
So,
so a friend of mine comes from
Washington with the Washington,
don't play games exact seattle's in the
house.
So,
so,
uh,
we,
we take this stuff with him and we put
it in cookies,
right?
Oh yeah.
And iT doesn't,
it doesn't take effect for an hour and
20 minutes,
nothing is happening.
So we said,
well,
let's go to dinner.
This is a classic story.
We go to dinner and all of a sudden I'm
just eating my first course.
I'm looking at the,
looking at the lights of the city from a
window and it starts exploding.
Wonderful.
So my wife was the third question on the
table.
She also starts feeling something and
she has to go to the bathroom.
So she goes on the way back from the
bathroom,
she passes out.
Whoa.
So I'd have to,
I have to go and try that.
Okay.
This is my woman.
I will take her.
I had to.
Anything.
So probably she got weak and therefore
best out,
don't pay any attention to her.
I'll take care of it.
And this friend or people from
Washington,
they have to watch them.
This friend doesn't know me.
He doesn't know her.
Just walks away completely.
It doEsn't go anywhere.
It just left you guys there.
Just left those guys there.
Wow.
What an asshole.
That guy is.
He caught up and apologize.
Oh,
eventually.
Did he know that you guys had taken pot
cookies?
Cookie or a brownie?
Wasn't he was taking.
We're gonna go to jail.
I didn't want to be a part of it.
I still get caught up in that.
In that difficult situation in the
future.
And for folks who have never heard me
say this before,
even though I've said it a million
times,
when you eat cannabis,
that has a completely different
psychoactive effect,
right?
When you're telling me,
yeah.
When cannabis is processed by the liver
produces something called 11 hydroxy
metabolite,
which is a approximately four to five
times more psychoactive than thc.
So that's why It has that insane effect.
It's not just insane.
It's an alien effect that you don't get
when you smoke pot eating.
It is a very,
very different experience and you could
easily overdo it and it looks like maybe
your wife just got so hot.
She's like,
I'm just going to pretend to be blacked
out.
It's way less stressful than walking
around.
Well,
she did say that she was faking
interdental bit.
See,
she did have to lie down and they fed
them anonymous.
affect mine to be under it and then
driving under it,
you know,
this is why I don't really like the idea
of legalizing marijuana in a sense
because driving with marijuana at least
be oral kind.
It's very,
very difficult to.
I mean I tell that driving experience
was the most difficult power in my
entire life.
I've never had that.
It just,
it's impossible to gauge time.
How time is going,
time.
There's fast.
Did it change?
Did it change your ideas of the quantum
world pot brownies.
So like connected to.
This was before the,
before the discoveries
of quantum physics that I went through,
but really those,
this is pre quantum physics quantum era,
the early eighties.
So in the early eighties,
you were a standard.
A nuclear theorists are struggling.
I already came out of bed,
but I had not found.
I discovered the new possibilities of
quantum physics.
Yeah,
yeah.
Before you discovered all this stuff,
you weren't really a happy guy,
were you?
No,
that was a very unhappy guy.
In fact,
you know,
my,
uh,
my change came only after I realized it.
one day I was at a conference on nuclear
physics giving a paper,
erudite paper,
of course,
nothing to do with everyday life and I
give this paper gusto.
Nobody appreciates it at this.
So I taught and I think that the other
guys,
although they are talking about equally
esoteric nonsense,
but they are much more appreciated by
the audience and at the party,
especially by the women.
The first sex.
Oh,
I'm jealous.
I'm just jealous,
jealous,
jealous.
Sending that equipped.
And that way,
the whole party,
the whole evening at 1:00,
I get disgusted with myself because all
my pumps are gone.
You know,
this,
tom's digestive hard buttons,
pills you eat,
a lot of times those days you weren't,
you were upset.
I'm upSet,
so I go outside this,
this is that on the on the monterrey
bay,
rePlace Scott Russell.
Omar and I have this ocean breeze hit my
face and I thought,
why do I live this way?
They this happy with so I literally,
I literally avowedly was the
practitioner of happy physics since
then.
Of course I didn't find it immediately
the way to be happy doing physics,
but eventually found it is
consciousness.
Physics is happy,
happiest years of physics that I ever
hoped.
So what?
What was this change though?
You,
you're sitting out there.
The water hits your face.
he's thinking and what?
Think it's an intuitive thought to
change one's life.
This is the kind of thing that happens
all of a sudden and you are not the same
anymore,
but you're not.
You weren't like descartes was visited
by an angel in his dreams.
You know what I'm saying?
Like your changes.
Like I just went outside and I'm like,
fuck this,
you know,
on mushrooms,
not the.
No,
no drugs,
nothing.
It was a moment that intuition at moment
of knowing yourself because I was ready
to look at myself.
You were ready to look at yourself
because before you weren't
before I wasn't before.
It didn't matter to me that the physics
that I do has nothing to say about the
life that I live and all of a sudden I
wanted to really live a meaningful life.
I wanted to do something that has
meaning,
not just in west to get ahead in my
profession.
So I wanted to integrate.
I want to integrate my professional with
my daily life,
how to love my wife.
I put up children how to get on with
trends better,
you know,
live life,
not just to physics formulas and publish
papers and get promotions in the
department.
Wow.
So it was just one moment.
You just had enough and that's when you
went into the woo world.
Well,
quantum mechanics,
not immediate.
Slowly,
slowly and um,
a lot of struggle,
a lot of experimentation,
a lot of steps in between.
It took a lot of time too.
This was 1973.
I might discover a kevin 1985.
So 12 years of quite a risky,
adventurous path,
but words came.
Now there's another thing that you said
that I read that I found completely
fascinating is that you don't believe in
freewill.
Well,
I do and I don't.
You do it in the sense that yes,
creativity has the component of favor.
Well,
it starts with the free will of the ego.
Ego has one freewill,
but she's very crucial element of
creativity,
which is bad.
At some point they got to realize this,
that it really does not know and
therefore start saying no to all
conditioning,
nor to condition meanings.
Now to condition habits,
no to condition patterns,
nor to condition behavior,
and that's when we make room.
That's when you have an open mind.
We make room for learning new stuff and
that's when creativity can come to us
before then we start really thinking
that we know it all with our reservoir
of knowledge because I have a lot of
expertise.
Therefore I know that expert is don't
bring us knowledge.
Expertise just bring us a very special
fraction of knowledge that is useful to
solve certain problems that would given
context because the context is known.
Therefore,
the expertise always says,
well,
somewhere in my expertise there is an
answer and it will develop a habit of
finding that answer fairly quickly and
people,
people admire that.
Of course you go ahead in your society
because they are very efficient problem
solver,
but I they did sing that happens with an
open mind.
They start to realize that there is a
real life.
Problems are not given within contexts.
The contexts are not given to you.
You have to discover not only the new
meaning,
but also the new context of it.
And this is what makes real life
problems very difficult.
This is why we're touching about this
earlier.
We don't learn that stuff,
you know,
they sent her brother are sitting in me
how to integrate that with the abstract
thinker of today.
This is not given in any book.
They said,
not given within given context.
So how do you get into this kind of
thing?
Have To creativity.
You have to become open first.
That okay with this rational mind,
which has only learned about abstract
thinking.
You're not going to integrate our,
my emotions of the hunter gatherer days,
uh,
with the one that is today who is all
the suppressed emotions.
They're not going to integrate.
We have to open up,
we have to recognize our ignorance
completely and invite creativity in our
life.
so that idea,
that idea was the most important idea
probably that eventually,
you know,
changed me as a person.
Wow.
So the,
the idea that is so insane.
I'm sorry,
this is hard,
hard way to hurt a widow,
wrap your head around it,
but in saying that you have freewill and
you don't have free will at the same
time.
So this is,
this is the freewill.
This said this is the free world,
but in other things with what is our,
well,
what choices,
what flavor,
what flavor of ice cream?
Well left or right,
good or bad,
on the basis of what you know already,
right?
Well,
basis of what you know and what you've
learned and what we admire in someone
who's learned.
Exactly.
Someone who evolved.
Okay.
So on the basis of the known,
all the answers are conditioned among
the condition spectrum of knowledge and
that that's really not,
you know,
it's sort of freedom,
but there's nothing to kroger.
It's freedom.
I mean,
nobody would give up that freedom if it
tied and comes and says that,
no,
you don't have the.
You don't have the choice to choose a
flavor of ice cream even I have.
You have to.
You have to take only one flavor.
Of course,
all of us would object and immediately
we know we don't want that will become
rebellious,
but it's that a different order of
magnitude than what is needed to
discover really new stuff.
That freedom,
that freedom,
which takes us to,
to really new and they're the ego's
threewill is not very helpful.
We have to open up to what means
spiritual tradition is called god's
will.
Is that god separate from us?
No.
It's also our will in some sense,
but coming from a higher consciousness,
that's the difference coming from that
nonlocal consciousness.
So real freedom of choice is beyond
egos,
freewill to that freewill.
That enables me to choose creative
answer.
Creativity,
well,
okay,
so real freewill only exist sort of in
the base animalistic world and at the
higher levels of consciousness,
free will doesn't exist because you're
connected to the collective
consciousness.
No,
no.
Stay there a little bit inaccurate.
There was some accurate in it.
It it.
It does not exist necessarily.
Also in the non rational,
the in the emotional,
non rational experiences of the pre
restaurant.
Either it comes to the,
comes from the intuition,
the next level,
so it really is the higher function
except you're right.
In one sense,
if we go out outside of the irrational,
rational is our biggest enemy in defense
of free will,
in the higher sense is a bigger enemy of
intuition than already more sense.
Rationality is the restaurant,
and so the idea that you can rationalize
any evil or abusive behavior for the
head of a corporation because it makes
money for your
right,
that that restaurant I fashion is our
biggest enemy.
Even bigger than emotions in defensive
to include emotions,
to improve positive emotions,
positive emotions are very helpful too
to intrusive.
So how would you describe what the
rational thing is?
The biggest enemy of what that sort of
thinking can also be a friend.
I don'T want to sound overly again.
Can be rationalized.
Everything you mean?
Rationalization,
stage,
rational thinking,
rational thinking is good generally.
But we don't do it all.
Only with that we can,
we can justify it.
Like today,
scientific materialists,
they justify everything,
all of their,
uh,
all of the.
Even the worldview itself,
right?
But that's not as a way that could not
be spiritual.
It could not be god because everything
has to be made up better.
What else can it be?
That's their,
that's their argument.
Basic argument just boils down to this.
What else can it be?
There is only this matters.
A pastime matter.
Muslim world.
That's nothing else.
If you started an assumption like that
that's sort closed as you completely,
that's not freedom anymore,
he will lose freedom because you're not
able to suspend your belief system.
If you suspend your belief system,
many other experiences immediately find
meaning,
but it has this kind of reciprocity
picked clothes,
emotions,
intuition.
There's a problem with the definition.
The word rational like you,
like you're being irrational,
you're not being right,
have some rational thinking and then
rationalizing,
which is a negative.
It's a very strange,
but if the idea of taking it,
taking it
too far,
when is that rasterized?
WhaT we are really saying is that you
are using restful thinking to where it
does not belong.
That's rationalizing.
We'd asked analyze the way where
intuition belongs to rationalize the way
her emotions belong.
So in Australia,
the new science,
the new science does it admits it's the
science of experience,
not just a sensory experience.
That material is,
I'll agree with a new science says that
our emotions,
our thinking and already intuition.
All three are valid ways of knowing and
audition to sensitive.
So we have four valid ways of knowing
physical,
vital,
mental and super mental,
deep intuition.
And when we imply all four ways of
knowing,
we go beyond it as not being
international being we go only the
physical way of knowing and the mental
rational,
logical way of knowing.
Michael shermer has a great point,
a great quote,
rather than the only thing smart people
are better at rationalizing their dumb
ideas,
which is a,
that's a very funny thing when it comes
to certain,
uh,
certain focuses,
certain things people do rationalize,
you know,
whether it's a environmental disasters
or you know,
doing things in other countries that are
unethical or immoral,
you know,
the,
the ability to rationalize and
especially the ability to rationalize on
a large scale like as a corporation is a
key problem with the civilization,
isn't it?
Keep prompting,
keep problem,
and how to get out of it.
I have a whole method of getting out of
it.
How do we do it?
I call it spiritual economics.
This same idea,
like the earlier story that I told you
this,
he found the wise person.
If it was that idea,
if we feed people these spiritual stuff
as consumer good,
right?
Suppose you could go out in the market
and buy happiness in the company of a
sage was very being makes you happy.
I've met such people who were,
are at,
what do,
I mean?
Does that make you happy?
You can,
you can lead them a little bit difficult
because they don't appear in every the
marketplace and not,
not,
no,
not like steven greer's,
but we could manufacture these people.
I think We now have the key.
We know about creativity so much today
that deep people are investing.
I think we really can inspire a lot of
very capable people in a lifestyle which
will generate happy.
Well let me tell you something,
what we're doing because this is not
something we ever set out to do.
When brian and I started this podcast
three years ago,
it was just on a laptop in my office and
we were just trying to have some fun and
we just doing it just to be silly.
We had done previous things like that,
webcasts where we had done them in hotel
rooms and you know when we were on the
road doing stand up,
but over the course of three years,
one of the things that's happened is
people have told us that what they've
gotten in this podcast and this
communication is they've gotten an
ability to interact or at least here
people interact that are like no one
they know,
so they're,
they're,
they're changing the way they think
about life there.
They're seeing that there's other ways
to look at things and in fact a lot of
your reality is shaped by the way you
choose to view the world and that you
can morph that and change that.
In this podcast,
and again,
we're not taking credit for it because I
didn't know it was going to happen,
has had an amazingly profound effect
effect on people.
Whereas I've talked to literally
hundreds of people that say the podcast
changed their life and that once they
started listening,
they started eating healthier.
Exercising.
They feel better.
They think about things better.
They try not to be a shitty person.
They try to be positive and they
understand and feel the effect of this
positive thinking.
Yeah,
I,
I agree with you,
and again,
we're not taking credit for this.
This is something that just happened on
its own.
It just,
is it a side effect of allowing people
into your life and into your way of
thinking,
openness,
that openness that says that.
Well,
okay,
we have this avid.
Yes,
and let's open it up.
Even though it's only for a couple of
hours.
Switch to is that I should really make a
call to my wife because I told her five.
Five.
Yeah.
Well we're going to wrap this thing up
anyway.
It's 5:30.
I don't want to wear you out.
Listen,
this is a.
This is a beautiful conversation.
Fascinating.
You're,
you're a very,
a really,
really interesting and intelligent guy
and it's hard to follow a lot of what
you say.
A two.
I think a lot of people are gonna.
Listen to this podcast.
Three or four times.
I think you did good.
Thank you.
How,
how the things are actually depends a
lot on the language we use and it is the
fact that we have a habit of using
languages like mind and consciousness in
an anonymous way that science cannot be
done that way.
What happens then is we don't understand
each other anymore.
So here you are not so much conversant
with the new science vocabulary anD here
I am without teaching you any recovery.
Just get right into the discussion.
And we had a discipline and some words.
What?
I don't even think it was a dissonance
quite honestly.
I think,
um,
I was just trying to really,
uh,
ex.
I was trying to play the part of the
person that is listening to this for the
first time.
I'm aware of these concepts of I'm aware
of your work and I really do appreciate
you coming on the podcast,
talk about it,
but it's a,
even for someone like me who's read at
least a half a dozen books on this
stuff,
it's hard to wrap your head around.
It is hard and it is also simple,
right?
I often say that quantum physics is
simpler than newtonian physics because
newtonian physics,
you've got very quickly the idea that
science can solve everything and in,
in,
in quantum physics,
because the choices brought into for it
from the beginning.
ImmeDiately start relating that,
hey,
I know about choice.
I know about this stuff.
Is sciences giving us this stuff
immediately,
mine mellows out a little and science
become more humanistic.
The last thing I wanted to ask you about
ken.
Ken,
let you go without this.
Um,
are you familiar with Dr.
James Gates?
No,
he's a theoretical physicist.
I'm a professor of physics at the
university of Maryland.
I'm with another guy named john.
He's the john toll professor of physics
at the university of Maryland.
He found self-correcting computer code
in the equations of string theory.
Um,
I don't know if you've,
if you've heard about this.
It was a really interesting,
again,
really hard to follow conversation that
he had with neil degrasse tyson who
we've had on the show.
And I talked to neil about it and even
he was trying to wrap his head around
the what,
what this meant,
but they found double and even self dual
linear,
excuse me,
doubly even self dual linear binary code
error correcting block quote,
which was first invented by claude
shannon in the 19 forties has been
discovered and embedded within the
equations of superstring theory.
You're laughing at this.
It's almost like you.
No,
I'm laughing because here we are talking
mainly about quantum physics and
consciousness sedentary.
You go into such a sophisticated
discussion of something that is remotely
connected with quantum physics of
course.
But um,
you know,
it could very well be,
but I'll tell you something,
they lost interest in such details.
this is fairly simple.
String theory is a good example of what
the idea that people propose when they
say the word pseudoscience.
Pseudoscience field of sciences that
were theory and experiment are both not
physical aspects.
It's just to re.
This is a good example of just theory
because string theory can never be very
far in our experience.
We just cannot do it.
It's talking about too high and energy
that we cannot simulate in the quiet,
in the laboratory,
nor in the high energy cosmology.
So in other words,
it's really a very,
very,
very far out.
So you know,
here we are at once the rational culture
that we call scientific materialism
that's intended date to talk about a
string theory,
which is highly abstract mathematical
theory,
not that they're not interesting as a
mind game,
certainly interesting.
And then they'll object things like
telepathy,
which is very much human.
Where the objection of course is that it
may not be quiet our proper science
because there may not be in a good
theory.
There may not be any good data.
so it was very strange.
We,
we,
we do because it has mathematics in it.
We call science,
which cannot be ever be verified.
Quite doable.
science
be science if it's not verified,
but it yet it's mathematic.
If it's math,
I agree you agree with me,
but say this is what puzzles me,
that,
that the culture is so obtuse that they
don't have,
they will never collect.
There are many concepts like that.
You know,
which because of that mathematical
nature,
they're accepted part of science because
their mathematical,
because mathematics is so vital,
it just felt
so.
You're not interested in this because
there's literally no way to know whether
it's correct or whether it's just
daydreaming,
right?
So I have a crazy way to make a living
vaguely interested because the one thing
there is something good,
very good about theory because it does
enable us to connect gravity to quantum
physics and that that problem is not to
be underestimated,
but I don't want the solution to come in
the form of a theory that can never be
very far.
Right?
So people should recognize that science
has two prongs.
In fact,
in my judgment,
tree theory,
edification,
experiment,
and then technology,
there's never going to be any
technological application of something
like string theory.
Never,
never.
IT's just too abstract.
Taking place in places that are so
remote from the human experience that
technology,
technological breakthroughs on the face
of it is,
you know,
at least for high energy physics,
you could always give it technological
justifications for in the form of
weapons technology.
Not particularly good,
but why technology at least is that
feasible offshoot of high energy
physics,
but these kinds of stuff,
you know,
it,
it's just been too far from my for my
taste.
We should concentrate instead of
problems which can immediately be
addressed,
problems that has impact on who we are,
what we are,
what we are doing here,
give us answers to real life questions
like how to run our life,
how to run our society,
how to run our economy,
and we have designs at hand.
That's what the New science is trying to
do.
Instead we have too much emphasis on
things that have not much to do with us.
The human condition superstring theory,
like super string theory.
Yeah,
I,
I've never been able to understand that
and I'm glad that you couldn't
understand it either or that it can't be
understood or that it leads to camp
verify,
but it doesn't need to be.
It doesn't need to be understood because
it can be very far.
That's my simple proposition.
Who needs to understand things,
clutter up your rein up for things which
has no consequence in my life,
and cannot even be very fair and can
never be built.
Never give rise to any technology that I
can relate.
There's so much crazy shit to
concentrate on.
That is actually real.
Right on.
Thank you sir.
It's been an honor to talk to you.
I really,
truly appreciate it.
Um,
what could people with.
What books do you have out that you
recommend that people could pick up to
learn more about,
about some of your
work when they basic quantum physics
stuff is best done in a book called the
universe.
God is not dead is another one.
And how quantum activism concepts
civilization has some of the
consequences of this theory to society.
do you have a twitter page?
Yeah,
of course you do.
Yes,
I didn't find it.
I'm gonna.
Go swami.
See you're funny on twitter here.
So I could send people to it.
Um,
yes.
nope.
That's not you.
It was some crazy.
Dude is laid here is love but innocent
here is knowledge.
But creative,
here's life,
but that's not you.
Right?
That's whack.
You wouldn't write something that whack.
Who is that guy catches me?
Is that you will find you.
Do you.
Do you know what your twitter name is?
You don't know what it is and no to
someone else do it for you.
Yeah.
Hmm.
That's ridiculous.
There's a lot of young there.
Unfortunately.
There's a lot of goswamis a shorten via
a whole lot.
How many?
There's a bunch of different ones on
twitter,
belieVe it or not.
yeah.
You've probably got a lot of fakers.
There's dudes who were,
you know,
what did you say?
No,
but I'm telling you there's a lot of
fakers out there.
Huh?
Can I ask a quick question on the,
on you said earlier in the podcast that,
you know now because of lasers and stuff
like that,
you can measure particles a lot more
accurately and that's how you found
that,
you know,
particles actually are moving.
Do you,
is the laser itself,
uh,
is that an accurate tool?
Has that been proven to be 100 percent?
Because what if it was just,
you know,
the laser saying that,
but then down,
you know,
20 years from now you find out,
oh,
it was just the laser.
NO,
no,
no measurement of distance.
So I'm part of macro object like a,
we're talking about tables and chairs at
that time in between,
you're looking at my looking.
They moved so very little and it's very
hard to observe with just ordinary way
that we measured like triangulating and
all that.
But with the laser beam,
because lasers traveling fairly,
very close to a straight line,
the diffraction effect is actually gone.
Very good straight lines.
So triangulation becomes very accurate
because you really can go a long
distance and even that small of a,
even that,
even that small measurement do contract
for measuring.
I found you on twitter.
Your twitter handle is quantum
activists,
quantum activist on twitter.
So ladies and gentlemen,
please follow him on twitter.
I'm going to write that right now.
Follow.
Okay.
And thank you very much.
Really appreciate it.
It's been a real,
a true pleasure.
Talk to you.
I really,
really enjoyed it and if you ever want
to come back,
if you have anything that you want to
promote,
please come back on.
We would,
would love to have you.
We'd love to talk to you more.
it's a real pleasure.
have leftover.
Thank you.
Uh,
if you go to audible.com
forward slash joe,
you will get one free audio book and 30
days off of audible,
the premier audio resource as far as
like audio books and podcasts and comedy
albums.
It's a beautiful company.
And uh,
they uh,
had been supporting this podcast for
awhile,
so we appreciate them very much.
A audible.com/joe.
Go there.
Get yourself a free audio book.
Is any of her books on available on
audio book?
Um,
I don't think that they're all available
as ebooks and kindle.
Oh,
they are.
But nobody's done an audio version of
it.
I don't think anybody has done an audio
version.
In fact,
if you can inspire some of these people
to do it,
I'd love it.
I'm sure they would love to do,
do they?
it's on amazon.
Um,
see if there's an audio version of it.
Yeah.
I'm sorry.
That's an inside joke.
Thank you sir.
I really appreciate dr.
Goswami.
I'm at.
I'm at my same right,
right.
Absolutely.
Okay.
Well,
how do you pronounce it?
Amit?
Amit goswami,
the quantum activist,
just quantum activists on twitter.
Thanks also to onnit.com.
That's o and it go there.
I use a codename brogan.
Save yourself 10 percent off any and all
supplements.
I'm a thank you to death squad.tv.
We got a big show or he's got a big show
coming up this thursday.
That's next week in.
It's already past thursday,
friday next thursday in san diego at the
american comedy company.
A fantastic little club in san diego.
it's yoshi,
obayashi billy bone now jason teebo,
tony hinchcliffe and brian red band.
It's a hell of a show.
San diego.
Go on down.
And then tonight at the ice house in
pasadena,
10:00
PM show bryan red band,
tony hInchcliffe,
maddie kirsch,
who,
who else
caught me off guard and sam tripoli.
Josh fade.
I'm tony hinchcliffe,
johnny pemberton
and me subscribe to the desk squad on
the podcast,
a desk squad podcasts on itunes where
you can listen to an excellent podcast
like kevin pereira is.
Where's he going?
He had to make a phone call.
Oh,
there ain't nothing out there,
man.
I'm a kevin.
Pereira was pointless.
What is triple x squared mf said and
live shows in the ice house tonight.
Ian edwards.
Right.
What is your posture is sessions.
by the way,
he was on conan wednesday,
so I go to a conan's,
a website and check has set out
wednesday.
Beautiful.
Really good.
All right folks.
We got a hell of a week coming next
week.
This podcast keeps rolling.
You dirty bitches.
We stopped for no man.
We stopped for no quantum theory.
We got monday.
We've got bas rooted in the fucking
house.
A tuesday.
Scott sigler who is a horror author,
and then we're working on someone
wednesday.
hopefully I'm going to be able to get a
justin wren.
He's the white guy that's been working
to save the pygmies in africa.
I don't know if you see the video of the
first time they ever saw a white guy and
it touched me.
It was a former mma fighter who's now
living in the Congo trying to help
pygmies fake photos.
I heard this over fake photos.
Oh no,
this isn't a really recent.
I think you're thinking of something
different.
Yeah,
it wasn't a photo.
It was a video and it was like staged.
Apparently this is not.
This is modern iphone footage of him in
the Congo meeting.
These pygmies and the little boys,
the little kids like they had never seen
a white guy before.
A alright you fox.
We love the shit out of here and keep it
together,
bitches and we'll see on monday.